good morning everyone the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
will come to order and I want to welcome
everyone who's here today as well as our
Witnesses without objection the chair
May declare a recess at any time
pursuant to rule 7D of the committee on
oversight and accountability and at the
discretion of chairman Comer Mr Jordan a
member of the full committee May
participate in today's hearing for the
purposes of questions I now recognize
myself for the purpose of making an
opening statement Welcome to our first
of many hearings concerning the
coronavirus pandemic
we are tasked to review all the effects
of the pandemic as well as decisions
made during the pandemic not just the
origins of covet 19.
however
we are here today at our first hearing
to ask the fundamental question that
this body has failed to ask three years
ago where did covid-19 come from
did it come from a natural spillover
transferred from a bat to an
intermediate source to a human
in other words did it come from nature
or was it the result of a laboratory or
research related accident in other words
did it come from a lab
this question is fundamental to helping
us predict and prevent future pandemics
protecting our health and National
Security
and preparing the United States for the
future
this question is not one that should be
dismissed out of hand and it cannot be
taken lightly and it must be
investigated thoroughly responsibly and
honestly
an investigation based on facts expert
opinions and without intentional or
unintentional bias
that is what the select subcommittee is
tasked to do
follow the facts conduct a fair
investigation and seek to deliver the
truth to the American people
ultimately we will strive to produce a
product that will serve future
Generations enhancing our capabilities
and operating procedures when we are
faced with the threat of another
pandemic
that is what is deserved that is what
Americans should expect from their
government
and this is one more way we can provide
for our defense
and the work has already begun
thus far the select subcommittee has
sent letters of inquiry to the
Department of Health and Human Services
the White House
and Dr Francis Collins of the National
Institute of Health
the office of the Director of National
Intelligence
Dr Anthony fauci the former Director of
National Institutes of allergy and
infectious diseases
and chief medical advisor to the
president
Eco Health Alliance recipient of NIH
funding grants to perform coronavirus
research
the department of energy Department of
State
and the FBI concerning their
intelligence and investigations
surrounding the evolution of covid-19
and any forensic findings they may have
discovered
and over the weekend we released a memo
highlighting new evidence that suggests
that Dr fauci prompted the drafting of a
publication that would disprove the lab
League Theory
that the authors skewed evidence to
achieve that goal and that the current
chief scientist of the World Health
Organization was an uncredited co-author
even though he appears to have
contributed to the piece entitled
proximal Origins
I think we've already established that
the select subcommittee will try to
leave no stone unturned to try to find
the truth
unfortunately the question of the
origins has been politicized
that's no secret it has driven most
people to their Corners rather than
driving a political scientific debate or
discussion
some say the virus came from nature that
according to recent papers discussed in
New York Times the science is
dispositive
some say it's too unique too primed for
human transmission that there's too much
circumstantial evidence that points to
kova 19 coming from a lab
as well in three years there's been no
track found to prove the covid-19
evolved naturally from an animal or a
mammal or tick
to become highly infectious to humans
the truth is we don't know the origins
of kova 19 yet for sure
we don't have a Smoking Gun
first the science behind kova 19.
the Genome of kova 19 is inconsistent
with expectations and is unique for its
group of viruses
covid-19 has both a binding domain
optimized for human cells and if you're
in cleavage site
or a small part of the virus that makes
it so infectious
that has never been seen before in a
sars-related virus
in other words covid-19 has unique
characteristics that made it very
infectious to humans
these have never been seen before in any
other viruses of its type
most viral outbreaks are slow and small
CDC data shows SARS infected
approximately 8 000 people worldwide
and eight in the U.S
similar with MERS which infected
approximately 2 000 people worldwide
but covid-19 was primed for human
transmission it has infected more than
750 million people worldwide
Dr Redfield one of our Witnesses here
today and a virologist has even said he
believes kova 19 had a detour from
nature to be educated how to infect
humans
second the known research occurring in
China
we know the Wuhan Institute of virology
was conducting gain of function research
on novel back coronaviruses by creating
chimeric viruses
combining two viruses together to test
infectivity and infecting mice with
these viruses
work that former covid-19 task force
coordinator Dr Deborah Burks confirmed
was in fact gain a function contrary to
statements by Dr fauci
we have learned that the Wuhan Institute
has poor biosafety and was conducting
This research
that only biosafety level two
described as the Wild West by Dr Jeremy
Farrar a virologist from the UK now
Chief scientist for The Who
we have learned through a leaked DARPA
Grant application that with U.S taxpayer
backing
the Wuhan Institute proposed inserting
fewer and cleavage sites into novel
coronaviruses
the same unique genetic aspect of covet
19.
and we know according to a state
department fact sheet
the multiple researchers at the Wuhan
Institute were sick with kova 19 like
symptoms in the fall of 2019.
before
the Chinese officially announced the
outbreak
third
concerning actions of NIH and Eco Health
Alliance records show that the National
Institutes of Health
while the U.S was under a moratorium on
gain of function research Exempted Eco
Health Alliance and the Wuhan Institute
from this very ban
records show that the National
Institutes of Health allowed Eco Health
to conduct risky research on novel
coronaviruses at the Wuhan Institute
without going through the potential
pandemic pathogen Department level
review board
records show that Eco Health violated
Federal grant policy and failed to file
its five-year progress report for more
than two years
records show that ecohealth violated the
terms of its Grant and failed to report
an experiment that resulted in gain a
function of a coronavirus at the Wuhan
Institute
fourth
for some reason that we do not yet know
leaders in the scientific Community took
action to attempt to convince the world
that they should not take the lab leak
Theory seriously
Dr Francis Collins stated he was more
concerned with harm to International
Harmony than he was with investigating
the lab League
Dr fauci said the lab leak theory was a
shiny object that will go away in time
the president of Eco Health Dr Peter
dazik orchestrated a letter in the
Lancet they called the lab leak a
conspiracy theory
a statement that directly benefited Dr
dazik himself
and for scientists after a conference
call with Dr fauci completely reversed
their position
Dr Christian Anderson said he found the
genome inconsistent with evolutionary
theory
and Dr Robert Gary said he really can't
think of a possible natural scenario
but a few days later published a paper
saying the exact opposite
a paper based on the new emails based on
the new emails we release claimed to be
prompted by Dr fauci himself
and fifth the intelligence
FBI director Christopher Wray confirmed
publicly that the FBI assesses kova 19
most likely originated from Lab incident
in Wuhan
in the Wall Street Journal reported the
department of energy now also believes a
lab leak is the most likely origin
these aren't run-of-the-mill agencies
the FBI used experts in biological
threats and was reportedly supported by
the national biophorensic analysis
Center and the department of energy used
its own Z division experts in
investigating biological threats
these are some of the facts as we know
them
but there's so much more to do
we are here today to try and understand
what and why
it's important to conduct this
investigation
discovering the origins is vital
it matters for the future of the world
and we aren't finished
we're just beginning
there will be more hearings and more
inquiries and more documents discovered
and we will follow every lead
I look forward to hearing from our
expert Witnesses today and I thank them
for joining us today
thank you
I would now like to recognize ranking
member Ruiz for the purpose of making an
opening statement thank you Mr chairman
today the select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic convenes for its
first hearing to discuss the origins of
the kova 19 pandemic an issue of vital
importance to our nation's Public Health
since the first outbreak of kova 19
researchers in the scientific Community
have worked tirelessly to evaluate the
virus and Advance our understanding of
its Origins
dozens of Studies have been conducted or
are currently underway to evaluate this
question
and under President Biden's Direction
and Leadership the intelligence
Community initiated a sweeping
assessment to get to the bottom of the
viron's origins
the facts are
the evidence remains inconclusive
therefore we must allow our scientists
and intelligence communities to gather
evidence without politicization extreme
partisan rhetoric or conspiratorial
accusations that vilify our nation's
Public Health experts
instead we should focus on developing
policies that prevent and reduce the
harm of future viruses and pandemics
as ranking member of this elect
subcommittee it is my sincere hope that
we can conduct this work in an objective
bipartisan way based on evidence to save
lives
however today's hearing marks a
concerning step down the path of letting
extremism get in the way of an inquiry
that should be led by science and facts
when House Republicans announced this
hearing with her slate of hand-picked
witnesses
I was alarmed to see someone who wrote a
book applauded by white supremacists
Mr Nicholas Wade's 2014 book a
Troublesome inheritance suggests that
different racial and ethnic groups have
evolved to possess genetic variations in
traits and behaviors tied to whether
they Prosper or not for example Mr Wade
speculates that certain populations have
evolved to develop greater innate
intelligence he writes that quote
intelligence can be more highly rewarded
in modern societies because it is in far
greater demand in court and conversely
he claims that certain populations have
been slower to experience an
evolutionary change he has described as
quote the transformation of a population
social traits from the violent
short-term impulsive behavior typical of
many hunter gatherer and tribal
societies into quote the more
disciplined future-oriented Behavior
observed in other populations
the notion that people of different
racial or ethnic groups are more
successful or intellectually Superior to
another because of predisposed genetic
makeup is grossly inconsistent with the
consensus of scientific and medical
scholarship that is why I sent a letter
to my Republican colleagues this morning
strongly urging them to disinvite Mr
Wade as a witness so as not to give
legitimacy to a man of such discredited
unscientific and harmful views
these views are dangerous and have no
place in a hearing examining the origins
of a pandemic that has
disproportionately and overwhelmingly
harmed communities of color in the
United States I'm concerned that Mr Wade
and his views have been elevated by his
participation on today's panel giving
him a platform reaching millions of
Americans
his participation Hurts The credibility
of this hearing
answering the question of how the novel
coronavirus came to be one that should
be driven by the need for thoughtful
policy Solutions whether the novel
coronavirus emerged naturally or as a
result of a lab leak does not change
this
and as our expert communities work to
advance our understanding of the virus's
origins
Congress should be focused on developing
Common Sense solutions to put people
over politics and protect our nation
from the threat of a future Public
Health crisis
there is still time for this select
subcommittee to change course to reject
extreme partisan rhetoric discard
conspiratorial accusations and work
constructively to save lives the
American people deserve nothing less
I yield back
I think the ranking member I would like
to remind the ranking member and all
those here that the ranking member was
informed of our Witnesses seven days ago
yet objected this morning now I
understand that they had some problems
getting their witness because of covid
but we just received who their witness
was today
also I'd like to point out that Mr Wade
is here as he was the editor of nature
magazine and Science magazine nature
magazine is the magazine not while he
was there but is the magazine that
produced and printed proximal Origins
so
we will proceed and I think that we will
proceed and I expect that our witnesses
will proceed in sticking to the topic at
hand today as opposed to trying to
deviate from it
uh
you'll have your chance Mr Metz you know
you'll have an opening statement our
Witnesses today
are Dr Jamie Metzel Dr Metzel served on
the National Security Council under
President Bill Clinton the state
department under secretary Madeleine
Albright
and as Deputy staff director for Senator
Joe Biden on the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee
he is currently a senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council
Mr Nicholas Wade
Mr Wade has worked in the field of
health and science journalism for more
than 40 years
he worked for nature magazine Science
magazine and was then the science editor
for the New York Times
he is now a freelance journalist and
author writing extensively about kova
19.
Dr Paul awater did I say that correctly
sir okay Dr awater was the president of
the Infectious Disease Society diseases
Society of America the largest
professional Society worldwide related
to infectious diseases
he is currently a professor of medicine
at Johns Hopkins University School of
Medicine serving as The Clinical
Director for the division of infectious
diseases
Dr Robert Redfield Dr Redfield has spent
more than 40 45 years in medicine and is
a virologist by training he served as
chief of the Department of retroviral
research at the Walter Reed Army
Institute of research
co-founded The Institute of human
virology at the University of Maryland
and was the director of the U.S Centers
for Disease Control and prevention from
2018 to 2021 serving during the pandemic
itself
pursuant to committee on oversight and
accountability rule 9g the witnesses
will please stand and raise their right
hands
do you solemnly swear or affirm that the
testimony that you are about to give is
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God
thank you please be seated
let the record show that the witnesses
all answered in the affirmative
the select subcommittee certainly
appreciates you all for being here today
and we do look forward to your
testimonies
let me remind the witnesses that we have
read your written statements and they
will appear in full in the hearing
record
please limit your oral statements to
five minutes
as a reminder please press the button on
the microphone in front of you so that
it's so that it is on and members can
hear you
when you begin to speak the light in
front of you will turn green
after four minutes the light will turn
yellow
when the red light comes on your five
minutes has expired and we would ask
that you please wrap up
I now recognize Dr Metzel to give an
opening statement
chairman wenstrup ranking member Ruiz
and members of the select subcommittee
on the coronavirus pandemic it is my
great honor to join you today we are
primarily here because the Chinese
government has done everything in its
power to prevent the type of
investigation into the origins of the
covid-19 pandemic that is three years
overdue and still urgently required we
are also here because there is more that
we in the United States can and must do
to push forward even if China continues
to Stonewall this includes establishing
a bipartisan U.S national covid-19
Commission
I've waited more than three years for
these hearings to be held getting to
this point has required a great deal of
effort by a small but tireless
self-motivated and highly capable
community of experts from around the
world who have refused to be bullied
into silence because so many of us have
worked so hard for so many years against
such ferociously strong headwinds to
help lay the ground the groundwork for
these hearings I joined you today with a
deep and sincere request that your
committee honor our work by making these
hearings as evidence-based probing and
solutions oriented as possible
understanding what went wrong and
determining how we can do better must be
the ultimate bipartisan and non-partisan
issue I happen to be a Democrat which is
irrelevant to our work together since
the start of the pandemic I have been in
close contact with officials in the
Trump and then the Biden administrations
and have worked with members of Congress
of both parties on the pandemic Origins
issue although My Views are laid out
more fully in my written testimony I'd
like to quickly highlight my key points
first and most importantly approximately
20 million people including over a
million Americans have died as a result
of covet 19. these are our parents
Partners children relatives colleagues
and friends we owe every one of these
victims and ourselves the fullest
possible investigation into how this
avoidable tragedy unfolded and our best
efforts ensuring that a catastrophe like
this never happens again second while
the question of pandemic Origins remains
open there can be no no doubt that a
research related origin remains a very
serious possibility if not a distinct
probability There Is No Smoking Gun
proving a laboratory origin hypothesis
but the growing body of circumstantial
evidence suggests a gun that is at very
least warm to the touch
those feeling otherwise also deserve to
have their perspectives and research
carefully considered we should all be
open to evolving our views as new
evidence emerges everyone working in
good faith to follow the evidence
wherever it leads is on the same side
those working to prevent this type of
investigation are not third it is
inconceivable that over three years
after this deadly pandemic began no
comprehensive and and unfettered
investigation into pandemic Origins has
been carried out nor is one currently
planned this Injustice is an insult to
every victim of this crisis and a clear
threat to Future Generations the primary
reason there has been no comprehensive
investigation into covid-19 Origins is
the reprehensible actions of the Chinese
government since the early days of the
pandemic China's government has
destroyed samples hidden records
imprisoned Brave Chinese journalists
gagged Chinese scientists actively
spread misinformation and done pretty
much everything possible to prevent the
kind of unfettered evidence based in
investigation that is so urgently
required every person on Earth must
demand accountability from China
calling for a full investigation of
pandemic origin origins in China does
not at all mean we shouldn't carefully
examine our own behavior and that of our
friends and allies in fact we must
fourth although scientific collaboration
including with Chinese scientists
remains critical to building a safer
future we cannot purchase these
relationships by our silence we must at
least match the courage of Brave Chinese
citizens like zhangjan who is rotting
away in a Chinese prison for asking the
same questions many foreigners seem
somehow afraid to ask there is no
possible way to establish the principle
of transparency and accountability
tomorrow without fearlessly and
unequivocally establishing that
principle today
fifth even if China continues to
Stonewall there are critical steps we
can and must take in the United States
and elsewhere to move this process
forward this includes establishing a
bipartisan U.S national covid-19
commission to examine the origins issue
as well as other failings and
shortcomings on the national and
international levels and develop bold
recommendations for next steps
sixth because the pandemic has taught us
at least I hope that in our increasingly
interconnected world we are all only as
safe as the most vulnerable Among Us
making us more secure here in America
requires we do everything possible to
help build a safer world including by
helping upgrade the World Health
Organization although some people have
criticized The Who for how it has dealt
with the origins issue it is my view as
outlined in my written testimony that
who Chief Dr Tedros adenom gabriesus has
been in many ways an unsung hero of this
process
chairman westrup wenstrup ranking member
Ruiz and members of the subcommittee our
world is entering a new era of
globalization where risks are increasing
across the board including the risk of
pandemics far deadlier than covet 19. if
we do not get to the bottom of what went
wrong with the covid-19 pandemic if we
fail in our efforts to fearlessly
understand all shortcomings and Shore up
the vulnerabilities this crisis has so
clearly exposed the victims of the next
pandemic our children and grandchildren
will ask us why we failed to predict
protect them when we knew what was at
stake and had the chance thank you
thank you I now recognize Mr Wade to
give an opening statement
thank you Mr chairman uh although it's a
gigantic distraction from the work of
your committee I think I should briefly
try to respond to uh the uh attempt by
ranking member Ruiz to discredit my
testimony by uh saying a number of
untrue things about the book I wrote
10 years ago on the biology of race this
was a determinedly non-racist book it
has no scientific errors that I'm aware
of it has no racist statements and it
stresses the the theme of unity that we
are all variations on the same Human
Genome my book was uh vigorously
attacked by obscurantists academics who
want everyone else to believe that there
is no biological basis to race and my
book was as welcome to them as pictures
of the Earth from space are to Flat
earthers I have nothing to be ashamed of
in my book it's the only place you can
now read about what the genome says
about human races and I hope that Mr
Ruiz if he reads it will be presently
surprised to find that it says None of
the things he says it said
with apologies for that digression Mr
chairman I would like to thank you for
inviting me to discuss the origin of the
covet virus and hope you'll allow me a
few extra minutes
um I'm a science writer and I worked on
two leading research journals Nature and
Science and then for 30 years on the New
York Times where I was an editorial
writer and a science editor this
background has given me some knowledge
of how the scientific Community works
I'd like to touch on two issues of
interest to committee where did the SARS
2 virus come from and why are we taking
lab League idea seriously only now
instead of three years ago
when the epidemic first broke out in
December 2019 natural origin and lab
League were two equally reasonable
explanations
but if the virus had emerged naturally
it should have left many telesale signs
in the environment none has yet appeared
despite the Chinese government's Keen
interest in finding them
as each month passes without such
evidence the natural Origins idea has
grown steadily weaker it seems to me
for labrik on the other hand the
evidence has been a building
here are two of the two of the three
strongest pieces of evidence in favor of
lab League
first the epidemic broke out not in some
random Chinese City but right in Wuhan
home of the Wuhan Institute of virology
we know that scientists there were
genetically engineering coronaviruses
under seriously inadequate safety
conditions and we know that viruses
escape from Labs all the time
clearly labrik has to be a strong
possibility
second that possibility became much more
concrete with the recent surfacing of a
grand proposal by the Wuhan researchers
and others
they applied in 2018
for a 14 million dollar Grant from a
pentagon program called project defuse
the essential ingredient of SARS II as
the chairman it says has said one which
makes the virus so effective is a small
genetic element called a fear and
cleavage site
Wuhan researchers said in their grand
proposal that they would insert this
very element into a group of
coronaviruses
and Not only would they place the not
only that they will place the element at
a very specific point on the virus's
genome called the S1 S2 Junction
now the dod turned the pro proposal down
it was too risky even for them but the
researchers may have done much of the
basic work already or could have found
other ways to finance it
a year later the sars-2 virus appears on
the scene and guess what
it possesses a fear and cleavage site
the only known member of its large
family of viruses to do so and the
cleavage site is position positioned
right at the S1 S2 Junction
why should Evolution produce at that
very time and at that very place
a virus of the exact type described in
the defuse proposal
surely much easier to believe that the
Wuhan researchers did exactly what they
proposed and generated the size 2 virus
in their lab
but if the evidence for library is so
strong why do so many people still
believe the virus came from nature
the reason is that the natural origin
Camp got his story out first always a
big help it's very successfully painted
lab leak as a conspiracy theory before
anyone Republican reposed it the
national media swallowed the natural
origin story unskeptically and once
committed to it failed to report
important country evidence such as the
diffuse ground
science journalists in particular it
seems to me fell down on that job by
failing to check out the virologist's
self-serving claims
the natural origin Theory did not
Prevail by accident it was promoted by
science administrators in the United
States and England including Francis
Collins and Anthony fauci of the
National Institutes of Health
the NIH is a National Treasure
and Collins and fauci's most prominent
leaders at the time are well known to
the public and on Capitol Hill
it's hard to believe
that in the Twilight of their long
careers they would seriously mishandle
an issue as important as the origin of
the covet virus
yet that is what the evidence seems to
point to
the campaign to discredit lab League
began on the evening of January 31st
2020 when Fati received an email from
four virologists led by Kristen Anderson
of Scripps Research they had all
concluded that sounds too because of its
urine cleavage site could not have been
made in nature
voucher was probably not too pleased to
hear that the virus might have escaped
from research that his agency has funded
a strange thing happened to the
virologist's conclusion
within four days Anderson in an email in
February 4 repudiated
deriding lab leak as a crackpot Theory
what made him change his mind no new
scientific evidence about the virus came
to light between January 31st and
February 4. but from that 180 degree
reversal a whole campaign was able to be
developed including highly influential
articles placed in nature medicine and
the Lancet
um I have some ideas about how this and
other research should be regulated which
I've described as my written testimony
I'll stop there
thank you I now recognize Dr awater to
give an opening statement I think
chairman winstrup ranking member Ruiz
and distinguished members of the
subcommittee thank you for the
opportunity to testify though I'm from
the Johns Hopkins University School of
Medicine I speak on behalf of the
infectious diseases Society of America
and my statements do not represent Johns
Hopkins
over one million Americans have died
from covid losses that magnify the
tremendous suffering among countless
families in our country as a physician
caring for patients with covid for over
three years we need to deepen our
understanding of the virus's origins and
apply experience from the pandemic to
improve our preparedness prevent disease
and save lives
investigations must be objective and
driven by appropriate scientific and
intelligence experts Who present
unbiased findings investigations are
ongoing there's no consensus yet about
the virus's origins the department of
energy with low confidence determined
the virus escaped from a laboratory in
China based on classified information
unavailable to the public
the FBI reached its conclusion with
moderate confidence
on the other hand many virologists
believe compelling evidence points to an
animal origin they conclude that
coronavirus most likely jumped from a
caged wild animal into people at a
seafood market
we may never know the origin
conclusively making claims that cannot
be supported sufficiently by available
data only fuels confusion and mistrust
regardless we can learn valuable lessons
from these investigations to prevent
outbreaks and pandemics of any origin a
robust Public Health infrastructure and
Global coordination are essential for
surveillance to identify track and
contain potential threats pathogens
respect no borders we must collaborate
internationally to Foster an
unsuspicious atmosphere where Global
Information sharing about infectious
diseases is transparent complete and
rapid
20 years ago the SARS outbreak provides
an instructive example of what can be
achieved through multi-country
scientific and public health
collaboration within six months these
Collective efforts were successful in
staunching the virus and it is not
reappeared
greater transparency about science
decision making and public health will
help improve health literacy and rebuild
trust in science and public health
including understanding why
recommendations evolve as knowledge
grows if people are better prepared to
understand science they will be more
comfortable deciding how to protect
themselves and their loved ones best
the U.S should invest in an expert
Workforce to leverage preparedness tools
to benefit all communities meaning
recruiting and training significant
shortages of public health professionals
laboratory scientists researchers and
infectious disease Physicians persist
Federal Investments are urgently needed
to fill these gaps basic translational
and clinical research are crucial for
our pandemic preparedness for example
rapidly deploying tests for a new
pathogen will enable quicker scaling of
testing capacity when new threats emerge
Investments should also focus on
developing Therapeutics for anticipated
pathogens including viruses and bacteria
including multi-drug resistant ones
sufficient infectious diseases research
capacity improvements to biosafety are
essential access to bsl4 facilities
assists in biosecurity research
therefore new bsl4 Labs should be
strategically placed throughout our
nation the federal government should
support biosafety studies including why
laboratory accidents happen their
frequency and other data needed to
create and update evidence-based
mitigation measures
enhanced potential pandemic pathogens
Epp research a type of gain of function
research has received renewed attention
such efforts can help understand
possible human pathogen interactions
assess the likelihood of an emerging
pandemics and inform preparedness
efforts including surveillance and
medical counter measure developments
while such research is inherently risky
requiring strict oversight there are
risks if we don't undertake this type of
research leaving us unprepared
unbiased bodies with appropriate
scientific expertise should perform this
oversight last year the U.S government
charged the National Science Advisory
board for biosecurity nsabb with
reviewing policies regarding Epp
research and dual use research of
concern dorc in January the nsabb
released recommendations to strengthen
the oversight of Epp and durc research
in the U.S and abroad remove blanket
exclusions expand research types
considered Epp strengthened guidelines
and increased transparency in the
research review process these guidances
can facilitate achievements with
improved appropriate guard rails I am
grateful for your attention and for
inviting me the infectious diseases of
society also thanks you for your
leadership and stands ready to partner
with you to learn from the pandemic and
to improve our readiness
thank you I now recognize Dr Redfield to
give an opening statement chairman
Winthrop ranking member Reese and
members of the committee I'm pleased to
testify today in support of the
subcommittee's important work to
investigate the origin of covid-19 that
has resulted in the deaths of over 1
million Americans
from 2018 to 2021 I served as the 18th
director of The Centers for Disease
Control and prevention during the Trump
Administration
as CDC director I oversaw the agency's
response to the Covenant 19 pandemic
from the earliest days of its spread and
I also served as a member of the White
House coronavirus task force
but perhaps more relevant for the
purpose of this hearing my 45 years in
medicine have been focused on the study
of viruses I'm a virologist by training
and by practice
prior to my time at CDC I spent more
than 20 years as a U.S army physician
and medical researcher at the Walter
Reed Army Institute of research where I
served as the chief of the Department of
retroviral research and I worked in
virology Immunology clinical research at
the Forefront of AIDS epidemic and other
viral threats
in 1996 I co-founded The Institute of
human virology at the University of
Maryland in partnership with the state
of Maryland the city of Baltimore and
the university system of Maryland where
I served as the Director of clinical
research and care and I also served as a
tenured professor of medicine
microbiology and Immunology
chief of infectious disease and vice
chair of medicine at the University
after that time at CDC after my time at
CDC I served as a senior Public Health
advisor to Governor Hogan in the state
of Maryland
as covid-19 began to spread across the
world there were two competing
hypotheses about the origin of this
virus
that needed to be vigorously explored
the first hypothesis is the possibility
that covid-19 infections in humans were
the result of a spillover event from
nature
this is a situation in which the virus
naturally mutates and becomes more
transmissible from one species to
another in this case from bats to humans
via an intermediate species
this is what happened in previous
outbreaks
SARS and MERS and earlier coronaviruses
that emerged from bats and spread
through an intermediate animal
the second hypothesis is the possibility
that the virus evolved in a laboratory
involved in gain of function research
this is a type of research in which
scientists seek to increase the
transmissibility or pathogenicity of an
organism in order to better understand
that organism and inform preparedness
efforts and the development of
countermeasures such as Therapeutics and
vaccines
under this Theory covet infected the
general population after it was
accidentally leaked from a lab in China
from the earliest days of the pandemic
my view was both theories about the
origin needed to be aggressively and
thoroughly examined
based on my initial analysis of the data
I came to believe and I still believe
today
that it indicates that covid-19 more
likely was the result of an accidental
lab leak than a result of a natural
spillover event this conclusion is based
primarily on the biology of the virus
itself including the rapid high
infectivity for human to human
transmission
which would then predict the rapid
evolution of new variants as well as a
number of other important factors
which also include the unusual actions
in and around
Wuhan in the fall of 2019.
all of which I'm happy to discuss today
even given the information that surface
in three years since the covid-19
pandemic began some have contended that
there's really no point in investigating
the origin of this virus
I strongly disagree
there is a global need to know what we
are dealing with in covet virus because
it affects how we approach the problem
to try to prevent the next pandemic the
understanding of the origin of covet is
critical to Future science research
particularly as it affects ongoing
ethical debate around gain of function
research gain a function research has
long been controversial within the
scientific community in my own opinion
coveted 19 pandemic presents a case
study on the potential dangers of such
research while many believe that gain of
function research is critical to get
ahead of viruses by developing vaccines
in this case I believe it was the exact
opposite
unleashing a new virus of the world
without any means of stopping it and
resulting in the deaths of millions of
people because of this it's my opinion
that we should call for a moratorium on
gain of function research until we have
a broader debate and we come to a
consensus at a community about the value
of gain of function research this debate
should not be limited to the scientific
Community if the decision is to continue
with gain a function research then it
must
be determined how and where to conduct
that Reserve in a safe responsible and
effective way
I thank you for inviting me here today
as we explore this important topic I
look forward to answering your questions
thank you
thank you I thank you all I now
recognize myself for questions
uh
I have said since we started this at the
goal of this committee would be to Come
Away with some capabilities or at least
standard operating procedures in an
effort to be able to predict the next
pandemic prepare for the next pandemic
protect ourselves from the next pandemic
and hopefully prevent the next pandemic
uh and but first I want to ask each of
the witnesses yes or no does the origin
of covid-19 matter to protect the globe
from future pandemics we'll go down the
line Dr Metzel 100 absolutely and
completely yes Mr Wade
Dr Al water yes Dr Redfield yes okay so
we're all on the same page there
uh Dr Metz I have a question for you you
know we've heard the testimony and we
know scientifically fact that we have
found in the past with these types of
viruses coronaviruses in particular SARS
MERS we found an intermediary my
question is do you feel that we as a
scientific Community around the world
have robust capabilities to do that type
of investigation to find an intermediary
we have the assets we need for that
technically we do and we know that the
Chinese government has actually been
very aggressive in trying to find that
kind of intermediate intermediary host
animal they've sequenced about a hundred
thousand animals they haven't found
anything in SARS as you mentioned those
intermediary hosts were found relatively
quickly and so given that the Chinese
government has every incentive to find
an intermediate host I think it's it's
very significant that that hasn't been
found but we have that capability and we
have everybody has a reason to want to
find it particularly the Chinese
government and I think it's very telling
that after three years we still haven't
found it Dr hour I ask you the same
question about those capabilities
I would agree that uh we have the
technical capabilities uh what I would
say though is with coronaviruses they
are highly mutable uh which I've
certainly we've seen uh over these past
three years as the virus has evolved uh
and regarding
um uh finding intermediaries there are
examples for example with Ebola virus
where we have not yet found a clear
intermediary despite looking very hard
and no one thinks that came about from a
lab accident uh you know uh decades ago
so
um I think it's still an open question I
think everything does need to ex be
explored and I there's always opposing
points of view here that need to be
weighed and not all hypotheses are
weighed equally
yeah I think it's interesting you talked
about them being highly mutable I assume
they can be mutable in a lab Dr Redfield
are you an advocate for a moratorium on
gain of function research particularly
research on potential pandemic pathogens
and why
yes I am I think that um
again I think the people that are
advocates for gain of function research
do believe that by doing this research
they somehow get ahead of the Curve
I'm of the point of view that we don't
need to make pathogens more
transmissible or more pathogenic in
order to get ahead of the curve we can
begin to deal with those pathogens as
they evolve I don't think this should be
a decision made by scientists alone
this is a societal decision there should
be a broad debate about whether This
research is really necessary and if so
we should decide how to do it safely and
responsibly I remind people when I'm a
CDC director one of the most difficult
things I had to do
as a 20-something year Army vet was shut
down for Dietrich
it wasn't very popular these guys people
were my friends I knew them but our
inspection showed that they were cutting
Corners in their biosecurity
requirements
and I felt that we weren't going to take
that chance with the Frederick Community
and Beyond and so I shut the lab down
for four to six months until they
corrected their biosecurity so I think
this is much more complicated than
people think
and if we are to go down that path I
would argue there's a few labs in the
world that should be with multiple
redundancy in containment to do this but
I'm not convinced it's to an advantage
and this is why the Wall Street Journal
op-ed I did I strongly recommend that we
have a moratorium on gain a functional
research similar to what we had in the
Obama Administration
in in one sentence can you provide a
definition of gain of function research
and I and I say that because there
becomes a little semantics sometimes I
believe within the scientific community
of what what is that Chimera and what is
gain of function yeah I think it's to
take a pathogen and try to increase one
of two things or both to increase its
transmissibility or its pathogenicity I
disagree with some of my colleagues at
NIH to say the definitions restricted to
a pathogen that's already a pathogen
if I make a non-pathogen pathogenic
that's gain a function
so in your expert opinion was the Wuhan
Institute conducted gain a function
research absolutely viruses thank you
so one one other path of questioning for
you Dr Richfield proponents of This
research claimant may result in vaccines
or maybe even stop a pandemic
Dr Redfield has gained a function
created any life-saving vaccines or
Therapeutics to your knowledge not to my
knowledge has gain of function stopped a
pandemic to in your opinion
no on the contrary I think it probably
caused the greatest pandemic our world
has seen
do you find any tangible benefits to
gain a function research at this time
I personally don't but I do want to
stress I think the men and women that
supported
are people of good faith because they
truly believe it's going to lead to a
potential benefit I disagree with that
assessment
thank you I now recognize a ranking
member Dr Ruiz from California for his
questions thank you Mr chairman the
select subcommittee's first hearing
should provide an opportunity for our
members to carry out credible
responsible oversight to prevent and
prepare for future pandemics instead
House Republicans invited a writer who
is Extreme and dangerous views have been
echoed by white supremacists to testify
on the issue of the novels coronavirus
origins in May of 2014 David Duke former
Grand wizard of the kluscus clan hosted
a radio show praising Mr Wade in his
book a Troublesome inheritance Mr Wade
are you aware of David Duke's Praise of
your views on his website
uh when my book first came out to Mr
Ruiz uh I think the uh the extreme right
wing thought it would help their cause
but they very soon uh drop referring to
it because when they actually read it as
many people who talk about my book have
not well he they found that David Duke
did read your book in fact he had a
whole radio talk show about it and
described it in detail and he did
endorse your views on a
postdavidduke.com promoting His Radio
Show he States quote here Dr David Duke
speak on the former science editor for
the New York Times who has now has
essentially embraced the scientific
racial truth that Dr Duke wrote
extensively about in my Awakening and
has written about for more than 35 years
you see
Mr Wade's book deploys dangerous tropes
and stereotypes about minority
communities under the guise of science
his assertions Define the overwhelming
consensus of scientists and researchers
including those in the fields of
population genetics and evolutionary
biology
Dr redfill is a former CDC director do
these views trouble you
I'm sorry
I was distracted I'm sorry I was
distracted what do the views that I
mentioned uh and the David Dukes
endorsements of Mr Wade's book trouble
you
I'm not a fan of uh David Duke at all I
I do think that Nicholas Wade and I
followed his work over 30 years is an
outstanding science reporter and
contributed substantially both in nature
science and of course leading the New
York Times you know there are 140
faculty members and experts who dis
strongly disagree with you in fact more
than 140 faculty members and experts
jointly condemned Mr Wade's book in a
joint letter to the New York Times book
review stating quote we reject Wade's
implication that our findings
substantiate his guesswork they do not
we are in full agreement that there is
no support from the field of population
genetics for Wade's conjectures Mr
chairman I'd like to enter this letter
into the record
my only comment uh so so I'm sorry Dr
Redfield so the point the point is
inviting someone with discredited and
dangerous views like Mr ways to testify
on the origins of this pandemic which is
disproportionately harmed communities of
color
is not responsible credible oversight
instead it undermines The credibility of
this select subcommittee
now let me turn to you Dr allwater
you are a practicing physician a
professor of medicine and the former
president of the Infectious Disease
Society of America
representing more than twelve thousand
Physicians scientists and public health
experts who specialize in infectious
diseases like covert 19.
for the sake of putting people over
politics what credible steps can be
taken to advance our understanding of
the novel coronavirus's origins in order
to prevent future pandemics
uh I think building trust among
scientists and public health communities
is essential because pathogens can
emerge from where we least expect it we
need to have the tools available to
rapidly analyze and then develop tests I
had dealt with patients very early in
the pandemic where we were making
educated guesses whether they had
covid-19 we need to have tests that can
be widely dispersed quickly and
treatments Dr our water is it possible
that we will never have the concrete
evidence to determine with certainty the
origins of covid whether it was a lab
leak or animal transmission well I think
that's entirely possible and therefore
we need to focus more on also be
forward-looking as well so it's looking
back so having said that and being
forward-looking would it be responsible
to start coming up with solutions to
deal with whether it was a lab leak or
animal transmission for example is there
an international body that promotes
safety guidelines and has the authority
to have inspections and incentivizes
foreign Nation labs to have transparency
so that we can be assured that labs are
safe in foreign country especially in
not so friendly foreign countries yes
and I think has already been hinted that
I think is essential for General uh
protection in in my research I couldn't
find one do you know of any such body
that exists no but I'm saying that's
absolutely necessary and what can we do
if it was an animal transmission looking
forward to save lives what can we do to
to better our ability to prevent that I
know it's difficult
identified early and contain it in other
countries before it spreads what can we
do well you know there were efforts a
few years ago to build surveillance Labs
under prior administrations in an effort
to anticipate and and help work with
other and what happened to those labs uh
I believe they were dropped or
discontinued due to lack of funding okay
thank you and I yield back
thank you and I thank the ranking member
for transitioning to questions Jermaine
to the hearing today I now recognize Dr
McCormick from Georgia for five minutes
of questions
Dr all water you said in your testimony
that investigations into the origins of
covid-19 should be objective and driven
by appropriate scientific and
intelligence experts Who present
unbiased findings that are not
politicized
according to evidence and previously
released emails on February 8 2020 Dr
Anderson who authored proximal origin
stated our main work over the last
couple of weeks has been focused on
trying to disprove any type of lab
Theory would you consider this statement
objective and unbiased
I really don't have enough of a frame of
reference to really make a comment on a
single statement
all right let's switch then you you
talked to uh
you you cited a couple papers last
summer in science that talked about the
evidence of natural origin
these papers claim to show dispositive
evidence against lab leak
now I went to medical school I'm an ER
doc I served lots of patients during
this pandemic until just recently and I
know how viruses work they're specific
to species for the most part correct
they often are but not always there
there are some that are coronaviruses
are probably one of the most widely
dispersed amongst the animal kingdom
okay and and given if we use the origins
of a species that was in the wild that
came to human contact and gave us the
the virus that in question wouldn't that
virus still exist in that species in the
wild
well I think that uh it would be likely
the case right chances are that's a good
answer right so how many species in the
wild have we captured that still had
this coronavirus in them because that
would be a very easy thing to do given
its wild uh its wide dissemination in
the human population and its proximity
to Chinese Wildlife how many wild
wild animals have been captured with
this coronavirus present in them
currently uh well uh the the answer is
no but on the other hand thank you no
that's okay I I appreciate it so
basically I'm talking about from a
scientific standpoint uh we understand
as a virologist and and as a student of
virology the good professor taught me
just like that yourself who who just
said that the evidence is that diseases
just don't go away in populations that
are contained in the wild and yet we've
extensively tried to capture the Chinese
government would benefit greatly
from showing us that this exists in the
wild and came to human population yet
not one evidence of a certain species
whether it be dog or bat has ever been
shown to have this virus that somehow or
another transferred to human yet that is
our main
evidence
and Theory to disprove that
albeit the Wuhan
lab that actually stated what they were
going to do and then had the same
problem occur that's a less likely
that's a less likely chance in your mind
is that correct
well I think the uh hypotheses remain
very open at the moment so so which one
do you think is more scientifically
based based on what we just discussed
well I I'm not privy to intelligence
community so you don't have an opinion
well um I think it is more likely at the
moment just based on my reading uh of a
zoonotic that is an animal-based so so
based on the fact that we need to extend
to both so you would tend to favor the
the hypothesis even though it has no
proof whatsoever that it actually exists
in the animal genome or that you're
going to favor that over the fact that a
Wuhan lab that said they wanted to do
this and then had an outbreak about the
same time that that's less likely got it
um first of all when you talk about
having trust that's the most important
thing you just stated in answer to Mr
ruiz's uh statement the most important
thing is trust how do we build trust
when there's no transparency from this
CCP when it comes to investigating the
origins of this disease how do we build
trust based on your statement
well I think amongst science scientific
communities uh that is probably not as
high a barrier but you know for the
politics I'd have to leave to others but
you just stated that's the most
important thing correct but yet we don't
have transparency on something that
would be pretty easy to investigate if
we had transparency correct
uh again I would leave to others foreign
but scientifically right we need to have
transparency to investigate something
absolutely okay and we don't right
uh well I I think this has been brought
up yeah okay so we agree on that that we
have no transparency on the one thing
that we need Trust on to investigate the
less likely cause of this disease so
it's just totally coincidental so with
that
I will state that he pretty much agrees
with me when it comes to the origins
just doesn't want to admit it thank you
very much I yield
I now recognize the ranking member of
the full committee Mr Raskin from
Maryland for our five minutes of
questions thank you chairman one strip
and Mr Ruiz for this important hearing
the covid-19 pandemic came to America in
2020 of course when Donald Trump was
president and that President's policy
failures magical thinking and total
recklessness caused according to his own
special advisor on covid Deborah Burks
the unnecessary death of hundreds of
thousands of Americans now apart from
the Urgent question of how to improve
our pandemic response from the debacle
that he presided over is the question of
how the covid-19 pandemic began this too
is a critically important question to
answer to help us prevent and prepare
for future pandemics answers must come
from objective fact-based investigations
informed by doctors scientists and
public health experts at President
Biden's Direction the intelligence
Community is also taking sweeping action
now to understand the origins of the
virus and to bring all relevant facts to
light whatever the origins of covid-19
whether it is bats or bureaucrats no
finding will ever exonerate or
rehabilitate Donald Trump for his lethal
recklessness in mismanaging the crisis
in America which cost us more than a
million lives indeed if covid was
actually the product of a lab leak or
the worst bio weapon of mass destruction
ever invented as some have argued and
obviously we don't have the scientific
evidence to say any of this yet it would
not only not remove Donald Trump's
culpability it would only deepen his
culpability in the most profound way now
why do I say that because over the
course of the crisis beginning in
January of 2020 and Lasting through the
spring on more than 42 different
occasions that we have identified so far
president Trump openly praised and
defended the performance of Communist
Party secretary and Chinese president XI
in his handling of covid-19 and boasted
of how closely they were working
together and boasted of she's openness
and transparency on January 22nd 2020
when the first case of covid was
identified in the U.S Trump stated I
quote we have it totally under control
when asked if he believed the U.S would
quote know everything we need to know
from China he said and I quote I do I do
I have a great relationship with
President XI January 24th he posted on
Twitter quote China has been working
very hard to contain the coronavirus the
United States greatly appreciates their
efforts and transparency it will all
work out well in particular on behalf of
American people I want to thank
president XI March 21 in a briefing he
assured us China has been working very
hard to contain the coronavirus he added
the United States greatly appreciates
their efforts and transparency it will
all work out well March 27th he posted
on Twitter just finished a very good
conversation with President XI of China
discussed in great detail the
coronavirus that is ravaging that is
ravaging large parts of the planet China
has been through much and has developed
a strong understanding of the virus we
are are working closely together much
respect because of time I'm just giving
the committee a tiny Taste of Donald
Trump's fawning star-struck sycophantic
Embrace of everything the Chinese
government was telling him in 2020 but I
will happily offer a lot more for any
colleagues who think that the hunt for
the origins will somehow absolve the
last Administration for telling
Americans that kovid would magically
disappear at Easter time or everybody
should just take hydroxychloroquine or
refusing to wear a mask or never
developing a national plan to defeat the
disease whether it was bats or leaks or
bureaucrats who caused it Donald Trump
was the biggest apologist in the United
States of America for president XI and
the Chinese Communist Party he could
have directed the intelligence Community
to lead a covid-19 Origins investigation
back in March of 2020 three years ago he
did not he wasted precious time
minimizing the risk of the virus and
lavishing his praise on President XI he
could have taken the origins of the
pandemic seriously and held the CCP
accountable he could have pushed back
against the CCP for interfering with the
who's investigation into its Origins and
he could have asked our intelligence
Community to intervene he did none of
those things
and everyone should remember that let's
take the politics out of it and let's
get to the bottom of what happened thank
you Mr chairman I yield back
I now recognize Miss meliatakis from New
York for five minutes of questions
thank you chairman for two years myself
and the other Republicans on this
subcommittee connected the dots we
exposed the evidence supporting our
strong belief that covet was developed
and leaked from the Wuhan lab and during
those same two years the same Democrats
that sit on this committee they only
hindered they obstructed they refused to
hold hearings and get to the truth now
we see mounting evidence supporting the
covid-19 originated from the lab in
Wuhan China run by the communist Chinese
party and this hearing is about getting
to the truth I thank the chairman for
making this the very first hearing
because the American people who have
seen just as many fellow Americans die
from covid
as nearly as many die from covid that
died in every war since the American
Revolution combined deserve to know the
truth
Dr Redfield you pointed to the lab
League Theory even before we did
in mid-January of 2020 you expressed
concerns to Dr fauci to Jeremy pharah of
UK's welcome trust and to Dr Tedros of
World Health Organization that quote we
had to take the lab leak hypothesis with
extreme seriousness and you urge Dr
fauci to investigate both the lab and
the natural hypotheses
shortly thereafter on February 1st uh
Farah convened a meeting of a group of
11 top scientists across five time zones
and asked Dr fauci to join and he wrote
quote my preference is to keep this
group really tight obviously ask
everyone to treat in total confidence
unquote Dr Redfield you were excluded
from this call but up until then you had
been on every single you were including
every other conversation what changed
why do you think that you were excluded
from these conversations
thank you very much I think just to
emphasize uh in in early to mid-January
I did have multiple calls with fauci
Ferrara and and Tedros about how
important I thought it was that science
get engaged in in aggressive aggressive
pursuing both hypotheses
I also expressed as a clinical
virologist that I felt it was
not scientifically plausible
that this virus went from a bat to
humans and became one of the most
infectious viruses that we have for
humans all viruses are not the same so
when you look at coronaviruses for SARS
and MERS for example when they entered
the human species which they did Via an
intermediate they never learned how to
go human to human even to this day they
don't know how to go human to human so
you can't equate Ebola with a
coronavirus now why do you why do you
think you were excluded from those calls
because it was I was told to me that
they wanted a single narrative and that
I obviously had a different point of
view okay and emails following the
conference call for the 11 scientists
told fauci that they all found the
genetic sequence inconsistent with
expectations from evolutionary theory
basically what you're saying however
just three days later these four
scientists had drafted a paper arguing
the exact opposite and that's now the
infamous proximal origin of SARS covid
II our investigations show this paper
was prompted by Dr fauci among others
with a goal to disprove the lab League
Theory what is the likelihood that these
scientists came across additional
information just three days after making
these statements to conclude with such
certainty that covid-19 came from nature
instead of the lab leak that they
thought it was three days earlier yeah I
think it's unfortunate again I've said
this before that this whole approach
that was taken on January on February
1st and subsequently in the month of
February if you really want to be
truthful it's antithetical to science
thank you science has debate and they
squashed any debate thank you given what
we know now and looking at all the
conversations in February of 2020 and
before the release of the paper do you
think that Dr fauci used this paper to
hide the gain of function research
created that grain of function research
created this virus
I can't talk about fauci's motivation
do you think that the paper does hide
the truth I think it's an inaccurate
paper that basically was part of a
narrative that they were creating
remember this pandemic did not start in
January at the seafood market we now
know there was infections all the way
back into September this was a narrative
that was decided that they were going to
say this came from a wet market and they
were going to do everything they could
to support it to negate any discussion
about the possibility that this came
from a library I got 20 seconds left Dr
fauci was affirmatively towed and told
in an email that ni Aid had a monetary
relationship with the Wuhan Institute
through Eco Health Alliance he he was
told this in January 27th of 2020. do
you think that Dr fauci intentionally
lied under oath to senator Paul when he
vehemently denied nih's funding of gain
of function research I think there's no
doubt that NIH was funding gain or
function research is it likely that
American tax dollars funded the gain of
function research that created this
virus I think it did not only from NIH
but from the state department usaid and
from DOD I'm out of time thank you very
much
now recognize Ms Dingle from Michigan
for five minutes of question
thank you Mr chairman
during the height of the covid-19
pandemic I found it very disheartening
to see public health professionals
across this country vilified and
attacked for supporting covid-19
mitigation measures basic safety
measures and later vaccines they were
trying to keep people safe and prevent
deaths
I want everyone to know I take this
committee very seriously I want the
facts Dr Redfield will confirm you I was
one of the first people to call him
about Wuhan and had a lot of questions
and never let up so I want the facts but
I hope and say to my colleagues on the
other slide we cannot go down a
dangerous path by pushing unfounded
conspiracies about Dr fauci and other
long serving career Public Health
officials
here is the reality
like many of you I am reading many
articles not just over the past weeks Dr
Redfield knows I've been on this from
the beginning talked to researchers
doctors Frontline nurses Public Health
officials they all agree on one fact
after the billions of dollars on
pandemic era upgrades to labs and data
and surveillance after all the studies
and white papers about emergency
preparedness the U.S still lacks two
things in the public health Arsenal
people and Trust
these continued smears on public health
officials is destroying them
I strongly urge everyone on this
committee but my Republican colleagues
specifically from rehashing unfounded
theories and other public health
theories that Dr fauci and other public
health experts have blocked
investigations into the pandemic Origins
Let's Get the facts Dr fauci has said
that we need to get the the bottom of
how the Navajo coronavirus originated
and have said and I've heard him say
like I talked to Dr Redfield he has an
open mind about the virus's origins
to all of you and all of us in this room
I say it's critical to rebuild trust and
that continued attacks on public health
officials only serves to further
discredit people's confidence in our
Public Health institutions makes it
almost impossible and it's challenging
to recruit workers in the field and it
undermines people's trust in science
you've we're seeing it we know the basic
things like washing your hands covering
your mouth when you cough and
immunization save lives and yeah because
of all of what we're doing people aren't
getting these invisal vaccines they're
not getting chicken pox we're seeing the
return of diseases that we've never seen
before
we have to take seriously that this
rhetoric is perpetuating people's
distrust in flu shots and many other
things
so let's work together all of my
colleagues to protect the American
people that's our job
Dr rwater how does misinformation
surrounding the possible origins of
covid-19 and its spread damage the
relationship between doctors and
patients
well my sense is it's a very frequent
question that you know patients just ask
me in the office what do you think and I
don't have any direct knowledge but it's
obviously on a lot of people's minds and
I think if it was handled objectively it
would be less political uh and uh and
therefore it sort of removes out of the
realm of also dovetailing with other
public health mitigation measures which
you so uh appropriately put forward uh
you know for uh the first part of the
pandemic we all wore maths I tell you no
one of my faculty got coveted 19
um until they you know people started to
not uh wear masks as well
um I think the efforts of trying to just
help the public early on when we don't
know a lot of information we always tend
to be more conservative and then as we
gain knowledge recommendations evolve so
I think the the origin story is
important to help again again look
forward and put forward measures to try
to help anticipate whether it's a
zoonotic infection or was a lab derived
virus I'm going to have more questions
for the record Mr chairman if you do it
but I want to switch subjects today
there are a variety of views within the
intelligence community and around the
world on whether the virus originated in
an accidental lab leak or whether it
occurred from Elite to animals to humans
and I want to know that more than any as
many as much as anybody but Dr rwater is
it normal for different agencies within
the intelligence Community to make
different assessments of the likelihood
of one origin Theory over the other
well I don't work in the government but
my understanding just reading the
newspapers are that the CIA has not made
any determination others have come to
different levels of conclusions so it
seems to me that there is a difference
of opinion and it's normal for
scientists to disagree absolutely I
think
debate there is always the case very few
things we know for certain I yield back
thank you Mr chairman
I now recognize the chairman of the full
committee Mr Comer from Kentucky for
five minutes of questions thank you Mr
chairman one of the prevailing themes of
the pandemic has been scientists use of
the media to downplay the lab League
Theory Mr Wade in your career you worked
at nature magazine Science magazine and
the New York Times would you agree that
the scientific establishment used the
media to downplay the lab League Theory
microphone
that's a complicated issue Mr uh Comer I
think the media was used it was used in
this particular campaign to establish
the natural origin Theory
um
uh the the Santa Fe Community is
is very afraid to speak up on political
issues and I think the reason is that
the government grants are handed out
through the system of peer peer review
committees and so you don't want you
don't want any single scientist on your
peer review committee to vote against
you therefore because you'll do you
won't get your gun it's so competitive
so therefore scientists are very
reluctant to get it to say anything that
is politically divisive or might turn on
the scientists off against them this
this means that
they cannot be relied upon in the way
that I think we would like them to to be
independent and forthright and call it
as they see it okay well we saw this
first with the proximal origin paper
that said quote our analysis clearly
showed that code 19 is not a laboratory
construct or a purposely manipulated
virus end quote this was first published
on February 17th of 2020. each witness I
have a simple question
yes or no was there science available to
make such an unequivocal statement
against the possibility of a lab leak
that early on in February of 2020.
absolutely no
Mr Wade uh no it was not
I I don't have sufficient I don't have
sufficient frame of reference to give an
answer no
next Peter dossick of equal Health
Alliance orchestrated a letter in the
Lancet a prestigious journal on February
19 2020 that said quote we strongly
condemn conspiracy theories suggesting
that covid-19 does not have a natural
origin end quote
each witness yes or no is the
possibility covid-19 leaked from a lab a
conspiracy theory absolutely not no
uh uh I would say no but also
um it has been approached to such
no
Dr Redfield I want to stick with you you
have said before that you were locked
out of conversations about the lab leak
by Dr fauci and Dr Collins
do you think they kept you out of the
conversations because you believe
covid-19 may have come from a lab
yeah I think I made it very clear in
January to all of them why we had to
aggressively pursue this and I let them
know as a virologist that I didn't see
that this was anything like SARS or MERS
because they never learned how to
transmit human to human that I felt this
virus was too infectious for humans
there was a lot of evidence that lab
actually published in 2014 that they put
the H2 receptor into humanized mice so
it could infect human tissue I think you
know we had to really seriously go after
the fact it came from the lab and they
knew that that was how I was thinking
although I thought we had to go after
both hypotheses and I was told later I
didn't know I was excluded I didn't know
there was a February first conference
call until the Freedom of Information
came out with the emails and I was quite
upset as the CDC director that I was
excluded in those discussions why would
they do this because I had a different
point of view and I was told they made a
decision that they would keep This
Confidential until they came up with a
single narrative which I will argue is
antithetical to science science never
selects a single narrative we Foster as
my colleague here just said we Foster
debate and we we're confident that with
debate science will eventually get to
the truth this was an apiary decision
that there's one point of view that
we're going to put out there and anyone
who doesn't agree with it is going to be
sidelined and as I say I was only the
CDC director right and I was sidelined
well I think Dr fauci and Dr Collins got
caught with their hand in the cookie jar
they got caught supercharging viruses in
an unsecure Chinese lab they wanted to
push the envelope and so they got
together to cover themselves
cover up their story and wipe their
fingerprint to the virus that is killed
more than one million Americans
the quote Jurassic Park
they were quote so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should end quote I
look forward to the rest of the
testimony today and I look forward to
the great work of this subcommittee Mr
chair I yield back
I now recognize Mr emfulume from
Maryland for five minutes of questions
thank you very much Mr chairman I want
to thank you and the ranking member for
convening us on this very important and
and difficult topic one that all
Americans regardless of where they live
regardless of what they do are concerned
about and I had come to this hearing
expecting uh Mr chairman that we would
find a way to peel off the things that
didn't matter so that we could get to
the things that did matter whether it
was a lab League or infection through
animals I think we've got to pursue both
of those paths if we are ever to get the
truth however I must go back to what my
ranking member said that I am a bit
appalled that this hearing now gets
layered over with the issue of race in a
very strong way with the presence of Mr
Wade and Mr Wade I have read your book
and I'm appalled by it and I would hope
that giving you this platform does not
paint or taint the issue that we're
trying to get to and deal with here
you're not a physician
you not a physician's assistant you're
not a scientist you've never done a
peer-reviewed paper and yet you've got
an opinion which is fine except that
it's steeped in this conspiracy theory
that somehow another minorities are so
genetically and different uh that they
are culpable in some sort of way and I I
just I don't I don't like that at all
um in your book
the Troublesome inheritance
you talk about a number of different
things and and David Duke talks about it
and says that he really endorses your
position on blacks and Jews
the book was championed by the infamous
white supremacist Jared Taylor John
demichire and Steve Saylor
the book has been promoted on a Neo-Nazi
forum
that is linked to almost a hundred
racially motivated attempted murders
over the last five years
and it troubles me that and I'm going to
ask unanimous consent Mr chairman that
the New York Times piece for which you
wrote actually said that your theory has
come off at the wheels particularly when
you talk about East Asians and their
genetic makeup I'd like to ask that the
David Duke statement and the copy from
his website be entered into the record
and I'd like that the Southern Poverty
Law Center which tracks these things
annually and their assessment which is
similar be added to the record without
objection
um
now I got to tell you I spent five terms
in this body
I was so troubled by what I saw in the
streets with bias and hate crimes that I
actually gave up my seat in the Congress
and I went back to work in community
groups I ended up being the president of
the NAACP so that nationally I could
work against this sort of thing it is
repulsive
and so here I am back again
hearing the issues that drove me out of
here to begin with and I don't want to
take away from this hearing I don't want
to take away from what I said earlier
that we've got to go down both paths but
it just burns me that I would know that
I'm doing that on a forum where somebody
with these sort of beliefs is also a
part of
Mr Ward I want to go to you for a minute
I know you don't represent Johns Hopkins
you're representing uh the association
on infection diseases I have a lot of
excuse me sir do I get a chance to
respond please it's my time no you do
not I know no you do not okay
I have a lot of respect for Hopkins I
spent 10 years On The Board of Trustees
there I'm a graduate of the institution
uh and I know that you speak with a
great deal of background and even though
in this instance you're speaking on the
association of infectious diseases I
take all of that very seriously and I
want to just say one ask you one quick
thing here about going down both of
these paths and how much can you say in
a short period of time does the
information obtained through this
hearing and other hearings and the
intelligence Community how very
important is that to bolstering the
efforts to prepare for any future
pandemics
well I I think obviously getting to the
origins is on everyone's minds but also
understanding what happened should also
help prepare us for moving ahead and I
can't under
um overstate the needs in our Public
Health which have been generally less
well-funded than other measures and
other diseases to help protect our
country thank you I've got to reclaim
the little bit of time I have left uh
and Mr Wade let me just say this
personally for race of people who have
suffered endured and survived three
centuries of slavery oppression
deprivation degradation denial and
disprivilege I'm absolutely offended
that you would have the opportunity to
take this platform and to add anything
of significance to it I yield back
well I don't have anything in common Mr
Wade Supreme Mr Wade
hold on a second
I do think that Mr Wade deserves the
opportunity to take two minutes to
respond
to accusations made but I do want to get
back to the topic at hand which is the
origins of kovid 19. uh thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry for this uh
distraction from the work of the
committee I'm sorry too that Miss
enthusi did not like my book I am not a
racist they don't have anything in
common with the views of white
supremacists just because they love you
though just because David likes my book
all of them I mean maybe he likes baby
would you please let him respond he did
not interrupt you I didn't know that he
got time to respond
likes my book he maybe he likes many
things that doesn't mean to say they're
all wrong I did not write my book for
him I also want to make the clearest
possible distinction between writing
about the biology of race which is a
really scientific issue and and racist
statements which I have absolutely no
sympathy my book is explicitly
anti-racist I stress the fact that we
are all variations on the same Human
Genome which I think is a very important
and unifying
um fact I I
I think the arguments made against the
book were for entirely political reasons
as uh the minority member referred to
the 120 scientists who attacked my book
in science well there's a nice story
about Einstein that someone told him
that 100 scientists had written a book
saying he was wrong and he replied well
if I were wrong one would have been
enough that's how science works not on
the number of people against it it works
on facts and and those letter writers
had no good point no mistake in my books
I don't think their criticism should be
taken carefully well I'm sorry for the
disruption and unhappiness this issue is
caused and uh let's get back to the
issue of the of the hearing Mr chairman
thank you I now recognize Dr Miller
Meeks from Iowa for five minutes of
questions
thank you so much Sean chair winstrup
and thank thank you to all of our
Witnesses who are here today I'm both a
doctor and a former director of the Iowa
Department of Public Health as well as a
military veteran of 24 years and like Dr
Metzel said I have waited three years
for this hearing
and I have in fact put people over
politics and science over conspiracy
our first inquiry on the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus crisis
this is my third year on this committee
was June 29 2021 on origins of covid-19
and the only people that attended were
Republicans we had a press conference at
that hearing and I was concerned that
the public and the Press weren't
conveying that it wasn't partisan in
trying to determine Origins it was in
fact of utmost importance and importance
not just to Americans but to the
International Community at that press
conference on June 29 2021 I said the
reason we need to know the origins of
covid-19 is to prevent and prepare for
the next pandemic we need to know one
there are immediate disclosure rules
there was not immediate disclosure of a
virus that would lead to a worldwide
pandemic immediate disclosure and who
has a vested interest in this and making
sure there's compliance laboratory
safety it was known even in the U.S
there are Labs who have lab leaks
laboratory safety biosafety lab for work
being done in a biosafety lab too it was
known that this was occurring at the
Wuhan Institute of virology so lab
safety and thirdly and I think that Dr
Redfield has mentioned this all of you
have mentioned this and that is the
ethics of gain of function research or
types of research often we as scientists
get ahead of the ethics but the ethics
of types of research and again the
International Community has a vested
interest in discussing and debating
these topics and I've published in
journals before peer-reviewed journals I
know how the editing and the peer review
process works and I also know very
intimately of the disclosure
requirements and conflicts of interest
including Financial
so over the weekend we release new
emails and documents that suggested that
Dr falty prompted the drafting of a
publication
ultimately called proximal Origins that
would disprove the lab leak Theory the
authors of this paper skewed available
evidence
to achieve that goal and Dr Jeremy
Ferrar now Chief scientist for the World
Health Organization went uncredited
despite significant involvement
so are you all aware of these documents
you can just not affirmatively
all of the witnesses except one have
nodded yes
um you know many of you have been in
journalism and in science writing for a
long time and so Dr Metzel can you
explain the process briefly because I
have little time of drafting editing and
reviewing of publication in a science
magazine
well Mr Wade is probably better at this
than me because he was an editor of two
science magazines but what I will say is
different people contribute and it's
normal practice to attribute to list the
names of the people who have
participated and then Mr Wade given that
acknowledgment so do you think it's
important that there's properly proper
crediting and acknowledging of authors
I I think the question of who is or is
not an author of a paper is somewhat
loose so many people interpret it
different ways there are things called
honorary authorships where you talk to
someone in an elevator and say oh I'll
add you to my paper
um it's not a very they're no hard and
fast rules for who should be author of a
paper but uh if an individual is the
Genesis of that paper do you think they
should be acknowledged
uh well if they make some important
intellectual contribution to it they
should I'm I I don't know that that
farad did or was in a position to all we
know is that he he suggested a minor
editing change to the paper
well and Dr rwater you mentioned that we
know the intermediate host for SARS how
long did it take for us to find the
intermediate host for SARS it did take a
few years it was not immediate and MERS
also took some time okay and are any of
you aware of a fear and cleavage site
occurring naturally
yeah Dr Metzel go ahead yeah they occur
naturally but not in sars-like viruses
other than sarsko V2 so in other viruses
but not in SARS on SARS cov2 very
similar to great no no no no no stars
like viruses and it showed up for the
first time in a sars-like virus in the
SARS cov2 virus which it seemed to
appear out of now the endonuclease
fingerprint
how common does that occur
the repeating cycle CG GC GG the the
fear and cleavage sites yeah yeah that's
my point in that is that there is
as you said Dr Metzel extraordinary
circumstantial evidence that this came
from a lab I don't know why the authors
didn't want to stay the state this they
did not want to have the scientific
conversation and dialogue why they
wanted to obfuscate and suppress the
truth or even have a debate about the
origins of covid-19 was it for personal
financial gain was it to hide U.S
financial interest into the Wuhan
Institute of virology indirectly was it
to suppress the revolution Revelation
that there was perhaps gain of function
research that had been prohibited in the
United States or were they concerned
that a conspiracy would develop that it
was bioterrorism and I would state that
their suppression and obstacation has
led to the exact mistrust and distrust
and conspiracy theories that they may
have tried to avoid thank you so much
I'm so delighted to have this hearing
and I think we will be able to get to
the to the bottom of this have an open
dialogue what they did is not science
I now recognize Miss Ross from North
Carolina for five minutes of questions
thank you very much Mr chairman
um I just want to be very clear to our
distinguished panelists and to the folks
who are watching this by Democratic
colleagues and I
strongly support the experts communities
efforts to determine the origins of the
novel coronavirus because doing so is
critical to preventing and preparing for
future pandemics plain and simple and as
stated almost 1.2 million Americans have
lost their lives due to covid-19 and
millions more around the world it's very
personal to each of us more than 30 000
people in my home state have died
because of this pandemic
and our goal here should be to prevent
something like this from happening again
which is why science and facts should
guide legitimate investigations into the
pandemic's origins and as has been said
by my colleague on the other side of the
aisle we must put people over politics
so Dr awater I just want to ask you my
first question how does promoting our
understanding of the novel coronaviruses
Origins help us prevent and prepare for
future pandemics well I think there are
two main Avenues one is if it is of
animal origin we need to anticipate
additional viruses or even potentially
bacteria and therefore having a advanced
notice and early notice is possible
certainly is helpful for containment and
also mitigation measures this no doubt
would need to be cooperation with other
countries Public Health agencies to
build that infrastructure on the other
hand if it's a lab derived virus then a
guidance in terms of proper research and
guard rails is highly important to make
sure to the best of abilities this never
happens again much as we take great care
with Airline safety nuclear weapons and
so on all that needs to be paid
attention to thank you dozens of
scientific research studies have been
completed or are currently underway to
promote our understanding of how the
novel coronavirus came to be
under President Biden's leadership and
we heard a little bit from our colleague
Mr Raskin about President Trump's
initial response to this but under
President Biden's leadership the
intelligence Community has taken
decisive action to get to the bottom of
the novel coronavirus's Origins and we
have seen some new releases from
different departments about their
ongoing findings Dr allwater can you
tell us about the importance of the
objectivity of these investigations
well as a clinician and someone that
does research I think the objectivity is
very important obviously not all
information is available to us that has
based the conclusions those outside of
my expertise as to whether that's the
case but I think the objectivity is
highly important and also the fact of
how it's rated you know low confidence
means exactly what I think it means that
there's a fair amount of uncertainty
okay final question
um Congressional investigations designed
to villainize or discredit public health
experts undermine our Public Health
institutions and sometimes can spread
dangerous misinformation which itself
can metastasize
um Dr rwater instead of launching a
partisan investigation or politicizing
the pandemic's origin what should
Congress be doing to prevent something
like this from happening again
well outside of the political realm I I
would just say an independent body would
make the most sense that uh is not
queuing essentially or have an ability
to make much political hay if that's
possible I'm not sure if the details of
that but to me that seems to be the
ideal thank you very much I'd like to
yield on the remainder of my time to my
colleague congressman mfume
oh thank you very very much for that I
want to go back and underscore if I
might uh how I began my comments because
I don't want that lost on those who are
here or those who are watching this is
design and again I want to commend the
chair and the ranking member Ruiz for
making sure that we move down a path
together together Democrats and
Republicans trying to get answers for
the American people
not just about what happened but as has
been said so that it never happens again
and if it does we're prepared and I put
so much emphasis on science because I
spent five years at the NIH at The
Institute for minority health and health
disparities I was the executive director
of the national Medical Association and
up until two years ago I've served as
vice president of research America the
largest research advocacy organization
in the country this is real to me this
is very personal and I just can't I
can't even fathom the thought of people
still dying as a result of this until we
have our work completed thank you I
yield back
thank you I now recognize Miss lesko
from Arizona for five minutes of
questions thank you Mr chair in
referees's opening statement he said he
doesn't want the covet investigation to
be political I couldn't agree more yet
in the next breath he accused one of the
witnesses of writing a white supremacist
book which is political Salvo designed
to discredit the witness then his first
question wasn't about covid-19 at all it
was all about a non-coveted related book
that Dr Wade wrote in the past and a
poster board was held over his head
designed for political theater
then rep Raskin went after president
Trump for five minutes instead of asking
a question
with all due respect I contend that some
of my Democratic colleagues are the ones
making the covet investigation political
why they don't want to investigate the
origins of covid-19 that killed millions
of people I will never understand my
first question is for Dr Redfield
a witness in our round table last week
said that it was a no-brainer that the
virus came from the Wuhan lab
when you were director of the CDC did Dr
fauci ever explain to you why he didn't
believe the virus came from the Wuhan
lab and why he actively worked to
silence that theory
Dr fauci's physician as those who
thought a spillover took the position
that it was most likely a spillover
event because that's what happened with
SARS and that's what happened with MERS
right and I think it's important to look
at prior to 2012 we didn't really have
another mechanism other than nature we
weren't doing gain of function research
right I'm a clinical virologist I tried
to explain to Dr fauci who's an
immunologist
that this virus SARS and MERS when they
infected man from the intermediate host
civet cat in the case of SARS and a
camel in case of MERS
they never learned how to go human to
human so those original outbreaks were
less than a thousand people and the
epidemics died
and so when everyone thought this was
sars-like well that's gonna it's gonna
die too but this virus was immediately
the most infectious virus not the most I
think probably right behind measles
virus that we've ever seen in fact man
so I immediately said wait a second this
is a natural and then you go back and
look at the literature and you find in
2014 this lab actually published a paper
that they put the H2 receptor into
humanized mice so it can affect human
tissue
and then you learn that the new covid
which came from bats now can hardly
replicate in bats yeah so how does that
happen so I said that my view as a
virologist again my hypothesis and I
never discredited them for their
hypothesis it's the spillover was that
this was most likely to come from the
lab and we need to aggressively
investigate both hypotheses thank you
thank you very much I have another
question for you Dr Redfield in a recent
Energy and Commerce oversight hearing I
asked the NIH acting director about the
nih's gross negligence in monitoring the
Eco Health Alliance Grant and sub-grant
to the Wuhan Institute of biology he
admitted that we might not have had all
of the information and research reports
from wiv and Eco health he insisted
however that he was sure that the
coronavirus research at wiv was
completely unrelated to SARS coven II
with the information we know
and the fact that China deleted data and
asked NIH to delete data
do you believe that we can have
certainty that the virus did not come
from the Wuhan lab and that U.S funding
was not used for covid-19 related
research yeah absolutely we can't do
that I will say if you go back and look
it's Declassified now and I'm sure you
all have your classified briefings but
the Declassified information now in
September of 2019 three things happened
in that lab
one is they deleted the sequences
was highly irregular researchers don't
usually like to do that second thing
they did was they changed the command
and control of the lab from the civilian
control to the military control
highly unusual and I've been involved in
Julius labs when I was in the military
and the third things they did which I
think is really telling is they let a
contractor redo the ventilation system
in that Laboratory
so I think clearly there was strong
evidence that there was a significant
event that happened in that laboratory
in September it's now been Declassified
you can read it I'm sure there's more
classified information around it
thank you Dr Redfield the New York Post
reported that you stated I could use the
word coverak cover up but I don't know
that so I'm not going to speculate that
do you believe there was a cover-up and
if so why would federal agencies work
with Legacy Media to silence scientists
and other Americans asking questions
about the origins of SARS kova 2. yeah
you know I'm not a big fan of quoting
the New York Post I don't think I use
the word cover-up okay I think there was
an attempt to misguide
redirect the debate
but I wouldn't have used the word
cover-up
thank you very much and I yield back
now recognize Dr Berra from California
for five minutes of questions thank you
Mr chairman um
you know from day one of this pandemic
unfortunately politics is kind of Infuse
a lot of this and I know this you know
obviously Dr Redfield you and I had many
conversations
in my time in Congress you know one of
my focus areas has been Global Health
security pandemic preparedness have sat
on National task forces at csis to
prepare for Global Health Securities we
put out our recommendations
unfortunately in the fall of 2019 and
have pushed to to put that framework in
place
my colleagues
congresswoman Dingle and congresswoman
Ross have equivocally said
as Democrats we want to find out what
the the origins of kovid were
um early on in the pandemic in January
of 2020 I pushed personally as hard as I
could on the Trump Administration to do
everything they could to get our
scientists to The Hot Zone to ground
zero to actually get a sense of what was
going on
I'm not going to defend how the Chinese
Communist party has handled this
pandemic they've stonewalled us they've
played politics they've you know Dr
Metzel you talked about the importance
of who
they played politics with the who
recommendations and until we actually
can get to the hot sun until we yeah I
don't know that we'll ever get the the
data
this is not a partisan issue in fact on
the intelligence committee which the the
chairman is on WE marked up the covid-19
Origins Act in a non-partisan way past
you know out of markup with a Voice vote
we will all get a chance to vote on that
bill on Friday I think you will see a
strong bipartisan vote encouraging the
intelligence Community to declassify as
much information as possible so the
public can see the information that we
have it's not conclusive but we've got
to continue to try to find the coveted
Origins
um
I think it is reprehensible that that
we're disparaging you know some of our
greatest Public Health individuals Dr
fauci Who I've known for a long time
um and Francis Collins who I've gotten
to know both are outstanding scientists
and so forth they may have had a
different hypothesis
we should entertain all hypothesis and
we should do it in an objective way to
find the answers I also hope we don't as
a body
um take the wrong lessons from this Dr
Metzel you talked about the importance
of the who
um I'd like your opinion on
International collaboration is extremely
important not just in pandemic
preparedness but also in biosecurity
work and so forth we have to have the
systems in place to identify pandemics
fairly quickly to think about how we
address it because you know whether this
was man-made or naturally occurring
Bad actors are out there who just saw
what a virus did to the entire planet
those Technologies are readily available
you come from a national security
background how important is it to work
with our International Partners here
it's absolutely essential that we work
with our International partners and with
The Who and has been said repeatedly
when those International Partners or
potential Partners themselves are Bad
actors which is absolutely the case with
China that makes things a lot more
difficult
and then the World Health Organization
which is absolutely essential is working
with one hand tied behind its back it
doesn't have the Mandate or the
authority to do what it needs to do it
couldn't have its own independent
surveillance capability in the beginning
of the pandemic when China was
preventing the who investigators from
going to Wuhan there was nothing that
that they could do and as I said in my
remarks Dr Tedros has actually really
been at the Forefront of fighting for
the kind of open inquiry that the
Chinese government has so aggressively
blocked and if I can just say just very
quickly I'm originally from Kansas City
I'm a Midwestern Optimist and so I hear
some consensus in the room that it's
critically important to understand how
the pandemic started that we have to
fully examine all origin hypotheses it's
my view as I've said before that China
is must be the primary focus
um because but we also have to look at
everything including ourselves but if we
make this process primarily about Dr
fauci even though we need to look at
everything if we make it primarily about
Dr fauci we will be inappropriately
serving the Chinese government a
propaganda coup on a silver platter I I
couldn't agree with you more let's get
to the facts let's discover the origins
let's do what we can to prevent the next
pandemic let's increase our bio safety
and biosecurity you know we should
debate gain a function research I think
that's totally appropriate we should
make sure if we are looking at that that
it is done in an absolute Safe Way with
oversight Etc we should also think about
the private sector that can operate you
know and do this research on on their
own we ought to think about how we also
look at that make that safer
think
now recognize Mr Cloud for five minutes
of questions
thank you chairman and thank you all for
being here thank you for for your work
in science and for yielding your uh
your wisdom in this effort to us today
um Dr Metzel I wanted to to ask you you
mentioned that there were scientists who
refused to be silenced uh insinuating
that there were efforts to silence and I
was just wondering if you could kind of
brief what some of those efforts were
sure so when a small handful of us uh in
the earliest days of the pandemic began
raising the possibility of a possible
lab origin there was just as I said
ferociously strong headwinds there was
this manufactured consensus and I kept
digging and like I said before I'm I'm a
lifelong Democrat I consider myself a
progressive person but I kept digging I
couldn't find the justification for
these strong arguments calling people
like me investigating looking into
pandemic origins in good faith
conspiracy theorists uh and it was very
difficult so we had a small group that
formed later in 2020 that is others have
called the Paris group all the members
of that community were aggressively
trying to place scientific papers with
journals and had zero success so there
was a wall that was extremely difficult
to take it over which is why what I said
to this group is look we have to try to
get around that wall and that's why we
we published our four open letters that
I believe had played a significant role
in along with other things of starting
to shift at this conversation but it
took more than a year of this kind of
aggressive work to to even start to
begin that type of change and some of
that pushback came from our government
too is that correct
well it was mixed I mean certainly from
what we've heard there were leaders of
the United States government who Dr
fauci had said he's he was open to all
possibilities but then the next sentence
was the preponderance of science
suggests a natural origin I'm a fan of
Dr fauci but I would I don't like to
scream at the television but when I
heard those those words I would say well
no no that's not the case that's not
what the science at least as I'm reading
it is is saying it to what you were just
saying Forbes mentioned you as one of
the first as an ex-high official high
level staffer for Bill Clinton and then
Senator Joe Biden to say that SARS
coronavirus was likely a Wuhan lab
escapee uh what what did why did you
think that yeah so in the early days of
January of 2020 like everybody I was
trying to figure out what was happening
and I read the news reports and it said
it can't it comes from the market and
SARS 2 sounded kind of like SARS one and
that seemed credible but I had just been
in Wuhan China and so I think a lot of
Americans had this vision of Wuhan as
some little market town where a bunch of
yokels are eating bats for dinner every
night but Wuhan is China Chicago it's an
incredibly sophisticated Highly Educated
wealthy City I knew that the Wuhan
Institute of virology was was based
there I knew a lot about that background
I also had I had an understanding both
of the science and of China and then on
January 24th of 2020 there was a Lancet
paper written by Chinese scientists
saying that more than a third of the
earliest cases of infection were of
people who had no connection to the
market and so in my mind that was a
pretty strong piece of evidence that the
market was a super spreader place which
is certainly is what I I still believe
and that was when I started digging and
then in later February of 2020. I had
all of these ideas I was developing I
went to South Africa for the meeting of
Our World Health Organization expert
advisory committee on human genome
editing and this is with some of the top
scientists and others in the world and
then privately I I said was telling
people like here is my private view
here's what I'm seeing in the evidence
and there was a part of me that was kind
of hoping that they would say Oh no
you're crazy here's what you're missing
because you know this is an
uncomfortable hypothesis for for many
reasons that wasn't that certainly
nobody was was saying that and that was
why when I came back after those
meetings I became very very public and
then I launched my website and wrote a
number of editorials in in March and
early April I want to try to get another
question yeah
your take on this was that before or
after proximal Origins came out so what
was your take on that when you I guess
read that yeah and and what impact you
see think that had on
the the scientific it's a community yeah
and the free Discovery so to speak of
it's a great question just I don't mean
to be overly referenced my own
background but I'm Pro science
pro-vaccine I I believe climate change
is change is real
um but when I saw that I was
monumentally I won't use a say upset
angry because without the available
evidence these absolute claims were were
being made and I was really digging and
there just wasn't the evidence to make
those assertions so the right position
in the beginning was what everybody is
saying now it could have been a natural
origin it could have been a lab origin
and we need to actively and aggressively
investigate all relevant hypotheses and
it's very unfortunate that wasn't the
case and of course the question we'll
have to get to later is why
was this
all the data deleted and everything
I now recognize Mr Garcia from
California for five minutes of questions
thank you very much Mr chairman I want
to thank of course all of our witnesses
as well for being here we all care
deeply about the work of this select
subcommittee I think it's critical and
we all can agree that we learned as much
about the Covenant of covid-19 Origins
um as we can we know that preventing
future pandemics saves lives that's what
this is all about that's what this
committee is all about of we've lost
over 1 million American lives in this
country many more across the world a lot
of folks know I lost both my mother and
my stepfather to the pandemic early on
so that I understand the human cost and
tragedy of this virus I'm very grateful
that uh in May 2021 President Biden
ordered the intelligence Community to
investigate the origins of covid-19 he
specifically requested the department of
energy Department of energy be brought
into as part of this important
assessment this has been discussed today
we know that this is critical work
that's been happening we also know that
one way or another we don't have Clear
Proof about the origins of kova 19 and
this has been shared by our Witnesses
and of course in in the many reports
that have been produced by our agencies
now we can make convincing cases of
course for both the potential lab leak
or or if there was transmission from
animals but no one can save for certain
what exactly the origins are today and I
think I want to repeat that so they can
be very clear to the American public as
far as where we're actually at in this
process and in this in these
investigations uh multiple federal
agencies have supported both sides of
the question and none with high
confidence one of the most important
lessons that we can learn from the
origins of covid-19 is how we can better
respond to Future viruses and future
pandemics as there will be future
pandemics we've seen the mass death the
devastation this has caused our economy
and the American public and the global
public and we also need to know and
understand what mistakes were made in
the past so that we can correct them in
the future
we know for example that President
Trump's own advisor in covid-19 who we
heard a lot from during the pandemic Dr
Burks had said that the previous
administration's policies early in the
pandemic possibly costs us hundreds
of thousands of American lives and I
want to also note something that was
said on we know that more the more than
20 separate occasions uh president Trump
defended president uh president XI and
his handling of covert 19. we've been
talking a lot about about China and
Chinese Origins so it's important to
talk also about what the former
president's comments were so even as we
had concerns about China's lack of
transparency early on in the crisis uh
president Trump would consistently
praise president XI in fact on 20
separate occasions I want to quote
something former president Trump said
quote last night I spoke to president XI
we talked about the experience that they
had in China and of all the things that
have taken place and we learned a lot
they've had a very tough experience and
they're doing well and he's doing well
president XI is doing very well but we
learned a lot and we have great
communication together we're going to be
sent great data from China end quote now
it's very clear that that great data
actually never came and there was never
really the cooperation that the
president the the former Administration
said that we were going to have and over
and over again president Trump's
Administration coddled the Chinese
government and told us that this was all
going to work out just fine even though
as doctors and scientists disagreed
if members of the subcommittee are as
concerned about the role of the Chinese
government in the origins of the
pandemic that we also need to take a
serious look at why the former president
repeatedly praised China and downplayed
a virus that was gone on to kill over a
million Americans that is the work that
the subcommittee should also be focused
on I'm Dr Redfield and you you mentioned
in a New York Times interview that your
greatest disappointment was lack of
constant Public Health messages from
Civic leaders and so my question is is
it fair to say that misinformation was a
major public health threat
I think that getting accurate
information to the American public was
was really important I was extremely
disappointed as CDC director
that I was restricted from being able to
communicate to the American public I
thought that was a disservice and and do
you think that politicians who spread
misinformation make the pandemic worse
and would it be fair to say that
politicians should promote vaccine
hesitancy actually cost lives
I think that there's a number of issues
clearly vaccine hesitancy is one of our
greatest threats as you know I've as a
CDC director I took it on head on when I
found out that you know we had over 360
000 people die a flu in the decade
before I was CDC director in less than
50 percent of American public takes the
flu vaccine so try to get over that I do
think and this is different I do think
one of the ways you promoted vaccine
hesitancy though that wasn't the intent
I do think when we got into vaccine
mandates that helped reinforce vaccine
hesitancy so vaccine hesitancy is a
threat we need to we we need to address
it thank you thank you very much sir and
I I I think that's important to also
note vaccine hesitancy has been has been
promoted actually by some members of
this committee is actually very
dangerous has been said by you and many
doctors across the country just quickly
Mr Redfield according to your March 17th
2022 transcribed interview with the
select subcommittee on the coronavirus
crisis you had you had a team of CDC
investigators prepare to go to China in
early January 2020 is that correct
correct but president Trump was not
successful in deploying this team to
China is that also correct correct well
thank you very much Mr chairman I yield
back
I now recognize Dr Joyce from
Pennsylvania for five minutes of
questions thank you for yielding and
thank you to our witness panel for
appearing here today Dr Redfield thank
you for appearing And discussing these
important matters one of the biggest
problems for our country going forward
has been the erosion of public trust in
our Public Health authorities both at a
national and at an international level I
believe that the work this committee
will do on getting to the bottom of the
origins of this virus will be critical
in restoring that trust and to that end
the House of Representatives will be
voting on legislation this week
requiring that the director of the
National Intelligence Agency to
declassify all information relating to
the origins of covid especially if there
is reason to believe that the Wuhan
Institute of virology is a source of
this outbreak Dr Redfield how important
is this level of transparency to restore
trust with the American public
you know I've thought about this a lot
of how we're going to get to the answer
that you're striving to get to what is
the origin
I don't think that answer is going to
come from the scientific community
I think that answer is going to come
from the intelligence community
and we need to get the intelligence
community and you all have the way to do
that I'd like to have you have each of
them show what data they have where they
got it who their informants were and
what their conclusions were because as
you know a number of them are on the
fence they don't say yes or no you got
you got the FBI and the energy
Department which I have a lot of respect
for because when you look at those two
departments the FBI and the energy
Department have the strongest scientific
footprint of any of our intelligence
agencies and I think the way they got to
the answers that low probability minor
probability is their internal scientists
did the science so so yes or no do you
support the declassification of all
information relating to the origins of
the covid virus I think declassification
is very important the only caveat that I
would say is there are some method and
sources issues that I think you guys are
going to have to wrestle with to see if
if they're compromised by some of the
declassification and I think that the
erosion of the Trust of the American
people needs to be re-established and
part of that is obtained I agree with
you I agree with you
I also I also mentioned that there's a
lock loss of loss of trust uh on
International levels uh and I constantly
hear that from my constituents back home
in Pennsylvania over the issues
specifically regarding the World Health
Organization by kowtowing to the Chinese
Communist Party who showed at every step
and unwillingness to be honest and
transparent about the timing the
severity and the origins of the outbreak
they badly damaged their reputation Dr
Metzel article 6 of the international
Health regulations requires that the
World Health Organization notifies
within 24 hours of all events which may
constitute a public health emergency of
international concern
do you believe that the Chinese
Communist Party complied with this
requirement given the reports that the
CCP had identified coven cases as early
as November of 2019 there can be no
doubt whatsoever that the Chinese
government violated the ihr do you feel
that there's an opportunity from our
group our work here to re-establish
potential trust in the World Health
Organization well that's a separate
issue certainly in the earliest days of
the pandemic Dr tedris by his own
Omission uh his own admission was saying
too many nice things about the uh about
the Chinese government when the Chinese
government was very clearly not
providing The Who that the information
of the who was privately asking for but
as I said earlier Dr Tedros then was the
essential voice after the deeply flawed
Chinese International joint study in
February of 2021 if Dr Tedros had not
spoken up basically condemning this
deeply flawed report and then abolishing
the entire uh this entire group we would
be in a very different situation today
the CIA
was given full veto authority over those
included on the investigation team and
coincidentally the only American
accepted was Peter dask who is CEO of
Echo Health sort of like heaven The Fox
and the hen house
with this information do you believe
that the conclusions of the report can
be trusted and is there a serious
conflict by dasek's inclusion in the
investigation team so as I've said many
times the entire process was flawed for
the joint study and that was a joint
study not originated by The Who
Secretariat but by the World Health
assembly which is the governing body of
states overseeing the who so this was
forced on the who the report of the
Chinese International Group in my view
was so deeply and fundamentally flawed
that it's it's outrageous but the SEC
The Who Secretariat they were the ones
who then Dr tezos rejected the findings
and then the who Secretariat abolished
that group and established a new group
the scientific Advisory Group on the
origin of Novel pathogens and that group
came out with this report that was
saying that that we have to fully
investigate a lab or origin and they've
called on China to be more cooperative
and China is again stonewalling I agree
that that full investigation of a lab
origin is the responsibility of this
committee I thank all the panel members
for being here today and Mr chairman I
yield
I now recognize Miss takuta from Hawaii
for five minutes
thank you Mr chair following up on the
gentleman's from Maryland's comments as
an Asian-American woman representing an
ethnically diverse District that would
find offense with Mr Wade's work and
conclusions in regards to race I ask
that the letter to the editor signed by
more than a hundred geneticists and
biologists opposing the use of their
research in Mr Wade's book be entered
officially into the record this speaks
to his professional credibility and
calls into question his very presence on
this panel
without objection thank you one thing
the covid-19 pandemic made clear is the
need for Reliable real-time Public
Health Data without it people of color
and the most vulnerable in our
communities are disproportionately
impacted we don't have the
infrastructure to get needed resources
to them and people die we in Congress
must continue to support our federal
Public Health agencies not just in
determining the origins of covid-19 but
in improving data and analytics
technology so we can pinpoint and slow
the spread of infectious disease at the
beginning of the pandemic we observe
difficulty scaling up the appropriate
Public Health infrastructure to track
and keep Pace with covid-19 this is a
catastrophic wake-up call that we were
grossly unprepared to deal with the
pandemic coupled with a lack of action
admission and Leadership at the Trump
Administration people died
Dr allwater let's focus on the facts and
let's put people first we need to
understand the origins of covid-19
there's no argument about that here to
prevent and prepare for future pandemics
what do Public Health agencies and
researchers need to do now learning from
this pandemic to ensure that we can
quickly test and Trace when faced with
new pathogens of pandemic potential
well my my work as a clinician deals
with public health departments I'm not a
public health department
person but each state has its own
department and then liaises with the
Centers for Disease Control and uh many
I know many of our state health
departments don't have enough funds to
accomplish what they want to each state
is sort of self-funding and has other
Federal monies too but there's just not
enough resources there's not enough
people and we have to go back to
Workforce issues trainees we need to get
people excited entering these careers
I'll mention that for infectious
diseases only 56 percent of our training
programs filled in 2022 there are a
number of reasons for that including low
compensation I know in public health
officials clinical laboratories we have
trouble finding people that want to do
that work and getting them into training
programs so these these are absolutely
vital from both clinical laboratories
Public Health Laboratories these are
Sentinel findings for you know trying to
see if there's an outbreak is there
something new impacting
um the health not only in our country
but then expand that internationally as
well because these same efforts are just
as important as keeping peace
thank you so clearly the federal
government needs to do more in terms of
support and resources to both our state
and local public health agencies in
order for us to have a strong
infrastructure set up regardless of how
the novel coronavirus came to be it is
important we continue to invest in
public health infrastructure and invest
in research on pathogens of pandemic
potential with appropriate guard rails
and strict oversight and guidelines to
do nothing quite frankly is to have
learned nothing from this tragedy and
set us up for failure and more death in
the future Dr Patel what would happen if
Congress blocked Federal funding for
bsl-3 and bsl4 Laboratories because of
misinformation and fear-mongering
surrounding lab leagues what would
happen if there was a moratorium on gain
of function research which includes
developing medical capabilities
countermeasures and surveillance
capacities
are you asking me
yeah are you asking me I'm sorry uh
sorry about that Dr all water okay
yes oh thank you uh so uh I think we we
you know if we have very strict rules
and shutdown or halt research within the
U.S there may be others outside our
borders carrying this out it's already
been mentioned that there are countries
that may not participate with uh
standard practices and and agreements so
um this is not an area I labor in but as
a clinician and for my infectious
diseases perspective within the society
I think
research that does examine these very
carefully and as you said with guard
rails with oversight
um is important and you know there can
be debate about where you draw the line
in terms of doing this research
um but I think not to do it could leave
us unprepared
um and of course there's different
points of view of this and this has been
going back and forth for a while but I
do think it needs to be vigorously uh
re-examined
thank you very much and I know Dr Metzel
you have also concluded these things in
your testimony as well
support for This research
yes it's we would be making a grave
error if we shut down virology if we
shut down epidemiology if we didn't have
a high containment virology Labs I think
everybody agrees with that the only
question is what are the guard rails and
when we have a situation such as this
where it appears very likely that a lab
error may have led to this whole
pandemic that forces us to to be very
careful and to do the kind of review
that we all need to to be working on
together thank you
now recognize Ms Green from Georgia for
five minutes of questions
if we're going to look into the origins
of covid and and fully understand where
this virus came from this virus that has
murdered so many people all over the
world I think the most important thing
we can do today is look at the timeline
and if we go back to early 2020 when
this was just starting to kill so many
people we'll see something interesting
that while Dr fauci Dr Anderson Dr
Collins Peter dazick from Eco Health who
by the way had a grant for gain of
function research Dr aachenklaus and
others were doing everything possible to
shut down the Wuhan lab Theory publicly
even though privately they told each
other
that covid-19 looked engineered and
discussed the reason to stop the theory
and if they were to
it's really interesting
they wanted to give reasons for not
expressing this opinion to the public
were that it would do great potential
harm to science in international Harmony
and do unnecessary harm to science in
general and Science in China in
particular even though they're
paychecks are funded by the American
taxpayers
at the same time this was going on
the CCP was using its full weight and
power to spread a propaganda campaign to
conceal the origins of covid
members of numbers of cases and deaths
and protect their own reputations while
stockpiling medical supplies severely
hurting the global supply chain and
definitely hurting America
in the same way the CCP silent censored
in prison dissenters who tried to tell
the truth Dr fauci and his cohorts
seemingly were running their own
misinformation and ultimately censorship
campaign
two in quotes from Dr Collins to Dr
fauci put down this very destructive
conspiracy
about the lab League Theory but it's
really interesting I think we should
revisit January 27 2020. Dr Anthony
fauci the director of the national
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
finds out that they have a financial
relationship with the Wuhan Institute of
virology through Eco Health Alliance and
that they've been working with novel
coronaviruses January 31st 2020 Dr fauci
is warned by Dr Christian Andersen that
some of covet 19's features potentially
look engineered
and the genome is inconsistent with
expectations from evolutionary theory
um Dr Redfield did you agree in your
opinion with Dr Anderson's assessment at
the time that this virus did look
engineered
I was concerned because of the presence
of the furing cleavage site that we've
talked about and I think it's important
to understand what that cleavage site
does
uh that cleavage site totally changes
the orientation of The Binding domain of
covid so it now which could not see the
H2 receptor which is the human receptor
it totally changes the orientation now
so it has high affinity for a human
receptor so that fear in clevocyte
bothered me it didn't seem that it
belonged there and then when you look at
the sequences that it used it's beyond
the committee but I know many of you
have looked into it the sequences that
they used in those 12 nucleotides for
arginine where the Arginine sequences
nucleotide triplet that are coded for
the human arginine so why did this virus
have the Arginine sequences for human
they're not bad it was very
disconcerting to me it looked like this
virus was engineered was this uh what
you're observing and speaking of is this
something that would be in line with
gain of function research and the
capabilities it would provide to the
virus yeah I mean basically this lab
published in 2014 that they accomplished
in this allowing the coronaviruses that
they were working with in the lab to
bind to the H2 receptor and humanize
mice and the only way they did that was
by reorienting The Binding domain and it
was clear to them at this time that that
was likely the issue in their private
conversations
um yet by February 4th a paper on the
origins of covid is drafted by four
participants of the February 1
conference call one of those
participants Dr Anderson completely
reverses himself in an email to the
president of ecohealth Peter and says
the main crop crackpot theories going
around at the moment relate to this
virus being somehow engineered and that
is demonstrably false my question to you
Mr Redfield did you know of any evidence
that they had found within three days
from February 1st to February 4th to be
able to confirm that it was not created
in a lab
um as I mentioned earlier unfortunately
I was excluded from those conversations
which I found retroactively very
disappointed since I was obviously a
virologist and very engaged and I
actually had asked Jeremy Ferrar Tony
fauci and Tedros to have these
conversations and then to be excluded I
found
unusual I do think it illustrates one
point that's worth really focusing on
when when you have a group of people
that decide there could only be one
point of view that's problematic
and I'll keep going saying it's
antithetical to science and
unfortunately that's what they did I can
tell you Dr Redfield that is the case
that's very problematic because how
people suffered in this country from
those uh what I would call
um
tyrannical decisions using their their
positions of power
um and shutting down the countries the
way they did I think people definitely
do feel that way thank you I yield back
I now recognize Dr Jackson from Texas
for five minutes of questions thank you
Mr chairman I appreciate it I want to
thank all of our Witnesses for being
here today uh Dr Redfield I want to
thank you in particular for your
services CDC director you were key in
getting some of the meat packing plants
back up and running during the height of
the pandemic in my district and I
appreciate that
um I just want to say I uh I agree with
a few things that have been said on the
other side of the aisle for my
colleagues and one of the things I want
to talk about it hasn't really been
addressed here from this side of the
aisle is that yes I do believe that
public health has been devastated by
this coveted pandemic but that is
because Public Health officials in this
country decided that they were going to
consider the politics surrounding this
issue when making statements and
recommendations that's the root of the
problem with the public health here and
yes this must be repaired we have to get
our Public Health the industry back the
only way that that will change the only
way that that will change is if we and
we and that we can regain the trust and
confidence that we have to have in this
country in our Public Health sector is
to look back uh look back at what
happened who made what decisions and why
those decisions were made and most
importantly if Public Health authorities
such as Anthony fauci
betrayed the trust of the American
people they must be held accountable
period somebody has to be held
accountable this is a problem we have in
government throughout government if
there's no accountability nothing
changes we're going to be doomed to
repeat this whole disastrous period in
American history again if we don't get
the answers about what happened and why
it happened
um so uh in in addition I just want to
say that that this continues to this
very day uh the The Who China the
mainstream media social media they all
need to be called out uh they need to be
held accountable for their part in this
cover-up millions of people died and we
need some answers to what what's going
on and I'll say that we still have an
issue with this today uh we we still
have an issue with corrupt politically
driven advice and this is evidenced by
the misinformation regarding mask
natural immunity the need for boosters
and most importantly and most important
to me at this particular time the
inappropriate efforts to vaccinate our
children so I would just say that we
have to regain this trust in public
health and we have to do it quickly
before something like this comes down
the pike again because American people
right now have zero trust and confidence
in the in in in the public health sector
in this country so I want to ask you
real quickly uh Dr uh Metzel and Dr
Redfield what do you think that we
should and could do to regain that trust
of our Public Health sector
a number of things first we need to look
objectively honest directly fearlessly
at the covet Origins issue as I've said
before I think the primary uh culprit if
that's the right word is China but we
also need to look at ourselves we really
need to look everything at everything we
need to follow the evidence we also need
to establish a bipartisan process for
evaluating the entirety of our Readiness
and that's why in my remarks I
recommended establishing a coveted a
bipartisan covid-19 commission kind of
like then built on the model of the 911
Commission because it's going to be very
difficult to do it piecemeal we really
need comprehensively in a bipartisan
matter manner to to develop an action
plan and because health is international
that means exactly as you've said we
need to focus on the national and the
international levels Dr Redfield real
quickly yeah real quick I think the
first and foremost is we've got to tell
the truth
when you don't tell the truth you've got
a problem and I think if you go back
there were many times when Public Health
officials packaged the message to what
they wanted to say but it wasn't
necessarily truthful
the second thing you have to have the
courage when you're a public health
official
to say I don't know when you don't know
and I think the really fundamental
that's how we begin to lose it when
people say that we're going to be okay
once we get 30 immunity and then later
they say 50 and then later they say 70
and then the Press says well why did you
say 50 before and now you're saying 70
and you and the guy says well I didn't
think the public was ready to hear that
you've got to tell the truth I want to
get a little bit of time here I want to
say how I said I did agree with some of
the stuff that was being said on the
opposite side of the aisle one of the
things I don't agree with and I think
that the way we have to fix this is we
do have to get past the politics now
that it's over and it's done with
there's been a lot of damage done we got
to get past that and I'm disturbed that
you know the people on the left in this
committee can't talk about this at all
without bringing up Trump racism or
conspiracy theorists and I just want to
make the clear the record on one
particular thing president Trump on May
29 2020 recognizing the failures of who
severed the U.S relationship with who
citing need for serious reforms and
despite despite this despite no reforms
taking place on his first day in office
President Biden rejoined the who which
was and continues to be nothing more
than a puppet of the Chinese government
I want to also say that on January 31st
2020 president Trump came under intense
criticism when he banned travel from
China an order then Presidential
candidate Biden called xenophobic a move
that even the highly respected Dr fauci
on the other side of the aisle praised
as CL as uh saying that Trump's actions
saved thousands and millions of lives so
thank you with that I yield back
I now recognize Mr Jordan from Ohio for
five minutes thank the chairman look
forward the Democrats tell us focus on
the future
might have started in a lab might have
might have happened in nature
but here's the question I keep coming up
with if it may have been a lab may have
been nature we're supposed to look
forward then why did Dr fauci work so
hard for just one of those theories
why was it so important to push one over
the other
Dr Barris said oh we should entertain uh
all hypothesis Dr fauci had his uh his
hypothesis how this started we should
entertain all of them
but that's not what happened
that is definitely not what happened
three years ago if you thought it came
from a lab if you raised that you were
called a nut job you got censored on
Twitter you were blacklisted on Twitter
you were even called a crackpot by the
very scientist who in late January sent
emails to Dr fauci and said it came from
the lab they called you crackpot is that
right Dr Redfield
I think the most upsetting thing to me
was the Baltimore Sun calling me a
racist because I said this came from a
Wuhan lab
Dr raptzel you were you're uh you you
ran the CD and you were on the
coronavirus task force is that right
correct that was formed on January 29th
2020 is that right correct two days
later Dr fauci gets an email from Dr
Anderson which says what virus looks
engineered virus not consistent with
evolutionary theory is that accurate
that's my understanding the next day I
know did he share that email with you by
the way Dr Redfield no as a member of
the task force as a head of CDC did he
share that email with you no okay next
day February 1st Dr Gary sends Dr fauci
another email that email says I don't
know how this happens in nature but it
would be easy to do in a lab did you
share that email with your doctor right
you didn't see either one of those
emails even though you're head of CDC
even though you're on the coronavirus
task force that have been formed just
two days three days earlier no three
days later Dr Anderson and Dr Gary who
told us it came from the lab and emails
to Dr fauci that Dr fauci wouldn't let
Dr Redfield see three days later they
changed their position
180 degrees
the question is why
Mr Wade why would they change their
position that fast when the only
intervening event is a conference call
with Dr fauci the guy who wouldn't let
Dr Redfield see the very emails that
they had sent him Dr Redfield head of
CDC on the chronovirus task force why
would they change their position Dr or
Mr Wade
well this question does lie at the hands
of the issue
what is burden and it seems to me is
there's there's no new scientific
evidence that we can see that came
available on between these dates the
January 1st and Feb four right there's
no new I think you're go ahead so you
have to ask if there were other other
kinds of influence available oh no it is
true that that um
Dr fauci and Dr ferry in London were
very powerful research officials and
between them I read your testimony I saw
that yeah so why don't you cut to the
Chase and tell them what you really
think was the reason I didn't know what
the reason was I know what it was I well
no go ahead go ahead I'll let you say
because I read your testimony I think
you you said it in your testimony too
maybe relax and say it here but go ahead
well if you're looking at the timeline
on May 21st
um just uh a few weeks after the nature
the the nation medicine would come out
uh two of the signatures of the original
email to Dr fauci that that's Dr
Anderson and Dr Gary were awarded a nine
million dollar ground for them so
there's nine million reasons why they
changed their mind I knew you'd get to
it I read that last night
three months after
so three days after they say it came
from a lab they changed their position
in the only intervening events a
conference call with Dr fauci and Dr
Collins again a call that Mr Redfield
was not allowed to be on the head of CDC
and on the coronavirus task force and
then three months later Shazam they get
9 million bucks from Dr fauci
well I didn't act something isn't that
something that's why we want to talk to
these guys that's why chairman winstrom
wants to bring in Dr Anderson and Dr
Gary and ask them a series of questions
so we can get to the bottom of this so
we can move forward and deal with this
now here's the key question like I don't
I'm not just a common sense guy from
Ohio my I well I was I majored in
wrestling in college but I got a degree
in economics you're supposed to get a
degree when you go to college I got one
in economics and one of the things they
tell you about is a thing called
opportunity cost so when you're spending
your time making sure that the country
believes only one of these theories
you could have been doing what Dr
Redfield was doing in our government
trying to figure out how we deal with
this virus and what was what was Dr
fauci doing he was trying to cover his
backside and everybody knows it and
that's the part that ticks us off
because this is the highest paid guy in
our government getting all kinds of
money to tell us things that were not
accurate because we now know U.S tax
dollars went to a lab in China a lab
that was not up to code a lab that was
doing gain of function research and
that's where this thing most definitely
came from and Dr fauci had to prove no
no he can't have that news getting out
and that's why he did what he did to the
exclusion of a brilliant guy running our
CDC kept him out of the loop keeping him
out of the loop probably potentially
could have harmed America
that's the thing that ticks us all off
and that's why Mr chairman this this
hearing is so darn important and we get
to the bottom of really what happened I
yield back
thank you at this point I'm going to
make a closing statement before
you you will follow me and then I will
yield to to you for a closing statement
you know this is a very serious business
extremely serious business
a political serious business
and I believe that Dr Ruiz ranking
member on this subcommittee feels
exactly the same way
you know there's a difference between
saying I disagree with you and here's
why
as opposed to label labeling something a
conspiracy theory or someone a
conspiracy theorist
there's a huge difference
that's the politics that comes in
we need to get it out
no more
for this committee and as a general
discussion Across America I hope that
that can change
I'm first the physician
I'm also a soldier
rack War veteran
I've served on the intelligence
committee here for the last 10 years
I've had a security clearance since
1998. as a soldier
this subcommittee is about an
after-action review Lessons Learned
through this process
finding truths
and building a path forward
so that we can have Readiness in the
future
that's what we need to do
my life has been about trying to improve
other lives to keep people healthy and
also about the security of the United
States of America
I'd love for this thing to be from
nature
I would love that
because that would be better for all of
us
but I can't help but look at this and
say there's another possibility here and
when I think of that other possibility
it leads my mind with my experience
in life to so many nefarious things that
can happen
to us as a people this is a national
security issue
this is a national health issue
some things might start out as good
I don't think the Wright brothers ever
intended for planes to be flown into
buildings to kill thousands of people
that may be the case
we need to consider all those
possibilities
the Lessons Learned I can give you some
lessons learned you know we're talking
about trust and building trust and I
will tell you going back to secretary
Azar I made the suggestion
America needs to hear from doctors that
are treating coveted patients
I think that would be the most helpful
that's who they know that's who they
trust those are the people in the
trenches not from politicians
and not from someone who's never at
bedside
just in the lab
the origins of of this is important
because
when we when we talk to doctors who are
treating patients for example though
this is where I think early on it was
most important because all they were
concerned about and and all Americans
were concerned about is whether they
were going to live or die
and will you come up with a cure or a
vaccine that's all they worried about
but as we try to move forward the
origins of this is important
so that we don't have to struggle in the
same way that we did through all of this
and trust is important
Dr Redford I agree with you on the
declassification
hopefully we will get there it's
important
for transparency for sunlight on all
this
obviously there's methods and other
things we have to keep out I get that
and you commented on another thing that
I had written down before you said it
because to me it's important as a doctor
to be honest about what we don't know
and when we don't know something and we
hypothesize something and then we find
out we're wrong we have to say we didn't
know and now we know better
that didn't happen
and I'll give you an example you know
early on these people were saying well
in the summer it may dissipate like
other coronaviruses have in the summer
that made sense
but it didn't happen
and we should have said oh my gosh that
didn't happen this thing is in the
called novel for a reason
and we need to do a little more digging
I am open to various opinions especially
from experts in the arena
included including doctors that are
treating affected patients
that's where we have to go
this committee is going to deal with all
aspects of the pandemic but this is one
that's very important and on the minds
of every American I want to thank you
all for your testimonies today for
taking the time to be with us
we may have to see you again we'll see
but at the same time I I do want to
thank all of you for being here and with
that I will
turn it over to the ranking member for
his final comments thank you I too want
to thank all the witnesses for coming
today and testifying uh before this
committee let me be clear my Democratic
colleagues and I take seriously the
charge of determining the coronavirus's
origins
and that is why we must allow scientists
and intelligence experts to do their
research without politicizations
or politicians politicizing the issue
using extreme partisan rhetoric or
making conclusions or accusations
without concrete evidence
it seems like mine's on the other side
of the aisle are shut and made up on the
origins and they have chosen their
villain
if we truly want to follow the evidence
the truth is that the evidence as we
have it now is inconclusive
but villainizing our Public Health
experts through conspiratorial
accusations based on partisan suspicions
and not concrete evidence does nothing
to help us prevent and prepare for
future pandemics
I too am a physician I too have taken
care of patients who have died due to
dyspnea in other words they couldn't
breathe they didn't get the oxygen and I
have intubated and kept people alive and
resuscitated people over and over in the
emergency department
these are not political ideas for the
individual who's diabetic and lives in a
poor neighborhood that doesn't have
access to testing or to or to Health
Care access this is not political they
can give they don't give two cents of
who knew what and by when
they want to make sure that they stay
alive that they can get the medicines
that they can can can live in a country
that doesn't have to politicize every
single damn thing and they want to see
their government work for them for the
people
to do the right thing and I do agree
that we need to evaluate the evidence as
it comes just like when we had the lack
of evidence of this novel virus and we
made as Dr Redfield and Dr R water said
some conservative uh decisions in order
to protect until we knew more until we
were able to have the resources to put
shots in arms students responsibly back
into schools people responsibly back
into work
but villainizing
our Public Health experts
undermines our efforts to do so you see
it hurts the recruitment of Public
Health servants in a time when we have a
public health servant shortage
and it hurts Trust
it hurts trust in basic basic Public
Health measures like masks that reduces
Airborne transmission
and vaccines that save lives
Congress has an important role in
supporting the expert community's
efforts to get to the bottom of the
coronavirus's origins
we also have an important role to be
forward-looking in developing the policy
Solutions
necessary to mitigate the threat of new
viruses no matter where they came from
you know I saw each of the witnesses nod
in agreement in my discussion with Dr AR
water regarding constructive policy
Solutions like
raising the international standards for
pathogen research
there is still an opportunity for us to
correct course
and this is a message on both sides of
the aisle for this select subcommittee
to be constructive body that focus on
forward-looking Solutions ones that save
lives that that matter to individuals
who are at risk of dying today from this
virus so this debate gain a function
research
let's discuss what we can do to improve
safety guidelines and transparency in
foreign labs
let's discuss how to increase trust in
public and basic Public Health measures
to save lives and recruit more public
health workers let's put people above
politics
we owe it to the American people to take
every action we can to save lives and I
stand ready to work with the chairman to
do so
thank you Dr Ruiz in closing I'd like to
thank our panelists once again for their
important and insightful testimony today
with that and without objection all
members will have five legislative days
within which to submit materials and to
submit additional written questions for
the witnesses which will be forwarded to
the witnesses for their response if
there is no further Business Without
objection the select subcommittee stands
adjourned thank you